When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tapas in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at Amex.ca. This episode is brought to you by Peloton. A new era of fitness is here.
作为美国运通白金卡会员，您可以享受独家餐饮体验和年度旅行抵用金。所以，城里最好的塔帕斯餐厅可能就在另一座城市。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。适用条款与细则。详情请访问 Amex.ca。本集由 Peloton 赞助播出。健身新时代已经到来。
Introducing the new Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus, powered by Peloton IQ, built for breakthroughs with personalized workout plans, real-time insights, and endless ways to move. Lift with confidence, while Peloton IQ counts reps, corrects form, and tracks your progress. Let yourself run, lift, flow, and go. Explore the new Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus. us at OnePeloton.ca. Why? Hello. Hi there.
隆重推出全新的 Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus，它由 Peloton IQ 提供支持，专为突破而生，配备个性化健身计划、实时洞察和无穷无尽的运动方式。在 Peloton IQ 计算重复次数、纠正动作并追踪您的进度时，自信地进行力量训练。尽情奔跑、举重、舒展，随心而动。探索全新的 Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus。请访问 OnePeloton.ca。怎么了？你好。嗨。
Welcome back to a second drink of women's appreciation. This is so fun. It's from writers Gene Stepnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, who we love. Our interview we did with them for Office 806.0 is one of my faves from the year. Same. Well, I've shared a lot about the standards and practices guidelines for the office. I mean, the emails from them to our producers are one of my favorite. things. And in re-watching this episode, I loved this observation about this episode from the website,
欢迎回到“女性欣赏”的第二杯。这太有趣了。它出自我们喜爱的编剧吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格之手。我们为《办公室》第 806.0 集对他们的采访是我今年最喜欢的采访之一。我也是。好吧，我已经分享了很多关于《办公室》标准与实践指南的内容。我是说，他们发给我们制片人的邮件是我最喜欢的东西之一。在重温这一集时，我非常喜欢网站上对这一集的观察，
Give Me My Remote. Remember them? Yes, of course. They said, here's what I don't understand, though. Season two's sexual harassment had a warning before the episode because of the word boner, but this episode was acceptable. I don't think the office has ever pushed the envelope in terms of sexual discussion as much as it did tonight. Michael, with his hands down his pants, oh my God, seriously, oh my God. I mean, where was standards and practices? I don't know. You know, we do say penis a lot. Yes. And you know, ladies, so many people wrote in about this episode breakdown. Many people loved our commentary on getting flashed in real life. They think we should put, and I'm quoting, I don't have time for your old man penis on some
Give Me My Remote。还记得他们吗？当然记得。他们说，我不明白的是，第二季的《性骚扰》那一集因为“boner”（勃起）这个词在播出前有警告，但这一集却被认为是可接受的。我不认为《办公室》在性话题讨论方面有哪次像今晚这样大胆。迈克尔把手伸进裤子里，天哪，说真的，天哪。我是说，标准与实践部门去哪了？我不知道。你知道，我们确实说了好多次“阴茎”。是的。而且你知道，女士们，很多人写信来讨论这一集的解析。很多人喜欢我们关于在现实生活中被暴露狂骚扰的评论。他们认为我们应该把——我引用一下——“我没时间看你那老头阴茎”印在一些
merchandise. What are we putting that on a coffee mug? What's that going on? Well, I think it needs to be on a to-go coffee mug. Okay. Right? Like a travel tumbler? Yeah. Especially if you're in a city with like a lot of public transit. Oh yeah. So you're riding on like the trains with like that I don't have time for your old man penis on your coffee mug. I think it could be helpful. Well, there were also so many candy bag alts for this episode. There are two pages of alts for Angelus Talking Head about shopping at the mall. I think the writers had some fun with that one. Oh, my goodness. Your character is clearly not happy about Michael's idea to take us out of the office. So they wrote a bunch of extra talking heads for you, but this one was my favorite. Field trips, at work, what's next? Recess. I shouldn't
商品上。我们要把它印在咖啡杯上吗？印在哪？嗯，我觉得它得印在随行咖啡杯上。对吧？就像旅行杯那样？是的。特别是如果你住在公共交通很发达的城市。哦，是的。所以你坐火车的时候，咖啡杯上写着“我没时间看你那老头阴茎”。我觉得这可能会有帮助。嗯，这一集还有很多糖果袋里的备选台词。关于安吉拉在商场购物的“谈话头”镜头，有两页的备选台词。我觉得编剧们在那一段玩得很开心。哦，天哪。你的角色显然对迈克尔带我们离开办公室的想法很不高兴。所以他们为你写了一堆额外的“谈话头”镜头，但这一段是我的最爱。工作时间去实地考察，接下来是什么？课间休息。我不应该
say that so loud, he might get ideas. Michael would love to have a daily recess. That would have been a fun, like, episode. Story in an episode, daily recess. Yes. Speaking of those scenes of Victoria's Secrets, Marley H. and others wanted to know where they can watch the blooper we talk about. Jenna, it's the one where Steve is Michael keeps messing with Angela Martin, but he's
大声说出来，他可能会有想法。迈克尔会很乐意每天都有课间休息。那会是一个很有趣的剧集故事，每天课间休息。是的。说到那些维多利亚的秘密的场景，玛丽·H 和其他人想知道他们可以在哪里看到我们谈论的那个花絮。珍娜，就是史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔一直在捉弄安吉拉·马丁的那一个，但他
messing with me in real life, trying to get me to laugh. We were filming in Victoria's Secrets. It's on YouTube. But Marley, there was so much more in the shooting draft for the scene. It was just this long, crazy list of suggestions from Michael of things he could buy for Angela. I want to read it. Okay. This was in the shooting draft.
在现实生活中也在捉弄我，试图让我笑场。我们当时正在维多利亚的秘密拍摄。它在 YouTube 上。但是玛丽，拍摄草稿里关于那个场景的内容还有很多。那只是迈克尔给安吉拉买东西的一长串疯狂建议。我想读一下。好的。这在拍摄草稿里。
Michael sits on a bench watching the women's shop. Angela sits next to Michael on the bench, checking her watch. For each suggestion, she demures. Michael to Angela. Nothing? Not even a scorte. Nighty, thong, boy shorts, laces, lacy's, frillies, bra, push up. Brow, Mary Widow, control top, garters, corset, girdle, edible panties, G-string, brief, string, bikini, strapless bra,
迈克尔坐在长椅上看着女人们购物。安吉拉坐在迈克尔旁边的长椅上，看着她的手表。对于每一个建议，她都表示拒绝。迈克尔对安吉拉说：什么都没有？连一条短裙都没有？睡裙、丁字裤、平角裤、蕾丝、花边、褶边、胸罩、聚拢胸罩、玛丽寡妇内衣、束腹、吊袜带、紧身胸衣、腰封、可食用内裤、G弦裤、三角裤、细带内裤、比基尼、无肩带胸罩、
C-cup, hip-hugger, boostier, pantalette, farthingale? You must use some sort of barrier between your clothes and your situation. Oh my gosh, I have so many things to say. Yeah, what is a Farthingale? What is a Mary Widow? I don't know. I'm looking it up. A Mary Widow is a type of strapless waist-synching corset. How does Michael know about this? Must be Jan. It's also a historical term for a sexually experienced woman, but oh my goodness, apparently there's even a cocktail called the Mary Widow? The Mary Widow? Who knew? Did not know. Okay, now look up Farthingale. It looks like it's another kind of corset, but okay, you know the really famous pictures of like, oh my gosh, Queen Elizabeth, and she has the little teeny waist and then like just the giant hips that come out.
C罩杯、低腰内裤、胸衣、衬裙？你必须在你的衣服和你的“情况”之间使用某种屏障。天哪，我有太多话要说了。是的，什么是衬裙？什么是玛丽寡妇内衣？我不知道。我正在查。玛丽寡妇内衣是一种无肩带的束腰紧身胸衣。迈克尔怎么会知道这个？一定是简告诉他的。它也是一个历史术语，指有性经验的女性，但天哪，显然还有一种叫“玛丽寡妇”的鸡尾酒？玛丽寡妇？谁知道呢？我不知道。好吧，现在查一下衬裙。看起来它是另一种紧身胸衣，但是好吧，你知道那些非常著名的照片，比如，天哪，伊丽莎白女王，她有细细的腰，然后臀部向外扩张得很大。
Yes, yes. Okay, so a farthingale is a corset that has like... Oh, like Queen Elizabeth I first. Yes. It has like a big round thing that comes off of it so that your skirt like poofs out real far. The things we're learning. But I have to say, finding out that Michael calls Angela's below the waistline the situation. I know.
是的，是的。好吧，所以衬裙是一种紧身胸衣，它有……哦，就像伊丽莎白一世女王那样。是的。它有一个大的圆形结构，从上面延伸出来，这样你的裙子就会撑得很大。我们学到的东西真多。但我必须说，发现迈克尔把安吉拉腰部以下称为“那个情况”。我知道。
Well, lady, in that whole speech, you called the store Victoria's Secret. I know. And it made me think about our conversation in this episode where we talked about how she just has one secret. And the secret is the bras kind of suck. And I'm not sure that it's a coincidence that this podcast has ever been sponsored by Victoria's secret or secrets. It's no secret. It's no secret. Well, Angela, I remember how you could not keep a straight face during this scene,
好吧，女士，在整个演讲中，你把那家店叫成了“维多利亚的秘密”。我知道。这让我想起了我们在这一集里的对话，我们谈到她只有一个秘密。而这个秘密就是胸罩有点烂。我不确定这个播客曾经由维多利亚的秘密赞助是不是巧合。这不是秘密。这不是秘密。好吧，安吉拉，我记得你在这一幕中是怎么忍住不笑场的，
and I pulled the blooper so that we could hear it. All right. I'm the candy man. Santa's come early. Sure, Santa, Santa would like to buy you a pair of panties, little girl. Santa would like... That's so gross. I mean, you didn't even get to the list.
我找出了那个花絮，这样我们就能听到了。好了。我是糖果人。圣诞老人提前来了。当然，圣诞老人，圣诞老人想给你买条内裤，小姑娘。圣诞老人想……这太恶心了。我是说，你甚至还没读到那个清单。
Well, what you have to know is the list came before. He sat there and just rapid-fired stuff at me, and I had to keep a straight face. And then he throws in Santa. And I was like, that's it. I'm out. I can't make it. But yes, Marley, you can find that on YouTube. Just type in the bloopers for season three.
好吧，你要知道的是，清单是在那之前。他坐在那里，只是快速地向我抛出那些东西，我必须保持严肃。然后他加入了圣诞老人。我就想，够了。我受不了了。我做不到。但是是的，玛丽，你可以在 YouTube 上找到它。只要输入第三季的花絮就行了。
Well, lastly, since I was digging in the candy bag alts, I have to share this one for Michael. We find out something he does after he, He and Jan, like, get it on that really annoys her. Oh, Lord. He says, it starts amazing. He says, you want proof I understand women. Here you go. Jan tells me she doesn't want me to sing to her after we make love anymore.
好吧，最后，既然我在翻糖果袋里的备选台词，我必须分享这一条给迈克尔。我们发现他在和简发生关系后做的一件事，这让她非常恼火。哦，天哪。他说，开始时很棒。他说，你想证明我了解女人吗？给你。简告诉我，她不想让我再在我们做爱后为她唱歌了。
Now, I know it's not the singing she minds because, hey, who doesn't like singing? It's the volume that gets to her. Oh, no. So what do I do? I hum very softly, but very melodically. And I'll tell you one thing, she hasn't complained since. There's so much information. So much information.
现在，我知道她介意的不是唱歌，因为嘿，谁不喜欢唱歌呢？是音量让她受不了。哦，不。所以我怎么做？我哼得很轻，但很有旋律感。我告诉你一件事，从那以后她就没抱怨过了。信息量太大了。信息量太大了。
What song is he singing? How loud does he sing it? And also, is this why he has to go sleep at the bench? I mean, there are a lot of things that I've learned since the dinner party episode that make me not judge Jan so much for the bench. You know what I'm saying? Like, I'm a little bit... I judge her for not leaving a guest room for him to go to.
他唱的是什么歌？他唱得有多大声？还有，这就是他必须去长椅上睡觉的原因吗？我是说，自从“晚宴”那一集以来，我学到了很多东西，让我不再那么评判简为什么让他睡长椅了。你知道我在说什么吗？我是说，我有点……我评判她是因为她没给他留出一间客房。
Yes, like she put all of her candles in the one room he could sleep in. And then the other one is her office. Right. Oh, she took up all the rooms. All the bedrooms. Well, I feel like we learned a lot in this Top of Show for the second drink. Mm-hmm. We sure did.
是的，就像她把所有的蜡烛都放在了他唯一能睡的那个房间里。然后另一个是她的办公室。对。哦，她占用了所有的房间。所有的卧室。好吧，我觉得我们在这一集的开头学到了很多。嗯哼。我们确实学到了。
And now, here's our breakdown of women's appreciation. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office. together and we're best friends and now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you we're the office ladies hello hi there today is women's appreciation everyone start right now think of a woman you appreciate appreciate that lady
现在，这是我们对“女性欣赏”的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友，现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。你好，嗨。今天是“女性欣赏”日，大家现在就开始吧。想一位你欣赏的女性，欣赏那位女士。
Appreciate her. Maybe pause. Give her a text message. But appreciate a woman. Because Michael is going to appreciate women today. He knows the crap out of women. And he is going to appreciate them. And I'm excited. I loved this episode. I loved filming this episode. I wrote about it in Madonna. Oh, lady. I can't wait. This is season three, episode 21, written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, direct. by Tucker Gates. Let's get right to it. After Phyllis is flashed in the parking lot, Michael decides to take the women to the mall to bond and unwind. The workplace was too masculine. So he wanted to take them somewhere where they could really relax. And that's the mall.
欣赏她。也许暂停一下。给她发条短信。但要欣赏一位女性。因为迈克尔今天要欣赏女性。他非常了解女性。他要欣赏她们。我很兴奋。我喜欢这一集。我喜欢拍摄这一集。我写了关于它的文章。哦，女士。我等不及了。这是第三季第 21 集，由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编剧，塔克·盖茨导演。让我们直接开始吧。菲利斯在停车场被暴露狂骚扰后，迈克尔决定带女同事们去商场联络感情并放松一下。工作场所太男性化了。所以他想带她们去一个她们能真正放松的地方。那就是商场。
Yeah. Oh, Michael. Well, while at the mall, Michael reveals how distressing his relationship with Jan is. Distressing is a word. Yeah, I had to come up with a word for the summary. I picked distressing. Yeah. And with the support of the women, he decides to break up with her.
是的。哦，迈克尔。在商场里，迈克尔透露了他与简的关系是多么令人痛苦。“令人痛苦”是一个词。是的，我得为总结想个词。我选了“令人痛苦”。是的。在女同事们的支持下，他决定和她分手。
Meanwhile, Andy and Dwight try to hang up sketches of the flasher. They're trying to find this guy. Right. The pervert. Yeah. Yep. The sketch was drawn by Pam and it heavily resembles Dwight. It's exactly Dwight.
与此同时，安迪和德怀特试图挂出暴露狂的素描。他们试图找到这个家伙。对。那个变态。是的。是的。素描是帕姆画的，它非常像德怀特。完全就是德怀特。
It's Dwight with a mustache. And no glasses. Oh, yeah. Finally, Kevin and the rest of the men in the office enjoy hanging out in the ladies' bathroom. Yeah. That is a crazy episode description. And that really is just barely touching the surface. It really is.
那是留着胡子的德怀特。而且没戴眼镜。哦，是的。最后，凯文和办公室里的其他男同事在女厕所里玩得很开心。是的。那是一个疯狂的剧集描述。那真的只是触及了表面。确实如此。
It really is. I mean, Meredith's Van isn't in that summary, and that's a whole... That Meredith's Van could be a whole episode itself. Oh, I wish we'd done an episode called Meredith's Van. Wouldn't you like to see that? Yeah, exactly. Or that's a spin-off right there, Meredith's van. Just Meredith living out of her van.
确实如此。我是说，梅雷迪斯的货车不在那个总结里，那本身就是一个……梅雷迪斯的货车本身就可以成为一整集。哦，我真希望我们做过一集叫“梅雷迪斯的货车”。你不想看那个吗？是的，没错。或者那本身就是一个衍生剧，梅雷迪斯的货车。就讲梅雷迪斯住在她的货车里。
Yeah. What are your fast facts, lady? Well, Ang, my first fast fact is about you. What is it? Is it true that you once had a flasher at one of your jobs? Okay, this is true. And I told this story in the writer's room. So I was talking to Greg on set one day about just,
是的。你的速记事实是什么，女士？嗯，安吉，我的第一个速记事实是关于你的。是什么？你曾经在工作时遇到过暴露狂是真的吗？好吧，这是真的。我在编剧室讲过这个故事。所以有一天我在片场和格雷格谈论一些
different things that happened when I worked at 1-800 dentist as an operator. And he was like, oh, you got to go up to the writer's room. You got to tell everybody these stories. So I did. And I'm not sure that this episode is 100% from the story, but I like to think it was a little bit inspired. So I was working at 1-800 Dennis in my early 20s, which was just yesterday, Jenna, really, right? Yeah, it really was. Just yesterday. And we had a man, he went into the women's restroom and kind of hid out in the women's restroom and then when women would go in there he would flash them and who was he we don't know he was like some guy from the street he was like went in the women's restroom okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait how did he where were your did 1 800 Dennis not have their own dedicated bathroom was it like
我在 1-800 Dentist 做接线员时发生的各种事情。他说，哦，你得去编剧室。你得把这些故事告诉大家。所以我去了。我不确定这一集是否 100% 来自这个故事，但我喜欢认为它受到了一点启发。我 20 多岁时在 1-800 Dentist 工作，那就像昨天一样，珍娜，真的，对吧？是的，确实是。就像昨天。我们有个男人，他进了女厕所，躲在里面，然后当女同事进去时，他就会向她们暴露自己。他是谁？我们不知道。他就像街上的某个家伙，他进了女厕所。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，1-800 Dentist 没有他们自己专门的厕所吗？它是
a whole building it was a whole building yes it was a whole building and several businesses you know the bathrooms were in the hallway you know what I mean yeah yeah okay like when I go to a doctor's office. Exactly. Exactly. Okay. Yeah, this guy, he came in off the street and he flashed one of the ladies when she went into the bathroom and she came running out and came in the office and was like, I just got flashed. And oh my gosh, 1-800 Dennis obviously took this very seriously and they implemented a whole new security system for our office. Okay, we are talking to people about their teeth. That's all we are doing. We're talking to people about their teeth. but guess what our security system was.
一整栋楼，是的，它是一整栋楼，还有几家企业，你知道厕所是在走廊里的，你明白我的意思吗？是的，是的，好的，就像我去医生办公室那样。没错。没错。好的。是的，这个家伙，他从街上进来，当其中一位女士走进厕所时，他向她暴露了自己，她跑了出来，冲进办公室说，我刚才被暴露狂骚扰了。天哪，1-800 Dentist 显然非常认真地对待这件事，他们为我们的办公室实施了一套全新的安全系统。好的，我们是在和人们谈论他们的牙齿。我们所做的就是这些。我们是在和人们谈论他们的牙齿。但你猜怎么着，我们的安全系统是什么。
Guess what the upgrade was? What? They scanned all of our fingerprints. And when we got to work, there was a scanner that you put your hand on that opened up to our hallway. Oh. I put my hand there and it would go blink, blink. Angela Kinsey admitted. Wow.
猜猜升级是什么？什么？他们扫描了我们所有的指纹。当我们上班时，有一个扫描仪，你把手放上去，它就会打开通往我们走廊的门。哦。我把手放在那里，它就会闪烁，闪烁。安吉拉·金赛承认了。哇。
Yeah. All because of the flasher. Yeah. But anyway, I told the writers that. that we had a flasher at work, and it caused all this big hullabaloo. And, you know, I just like to think that went on a note card on the wall somewhere. I want to give you credit for that. Oh, well, thanks.
是的。全都是因为那个暴露狂。是的。但不管怎样，我告诉了编剧们。我们工作时有个暴露狂，这引起了很大的骚动。而且，你知道，我只是喜欢认为那张纸条贴在墙上的某个地方。我想把功劳归给你。哦，好吧，谢谢。
I like it. All right. Well, are you ready for Fast fact number two? Yeah. Fast fact number two, this episode originally aired in May of 2007, and it is a super-sized episode. Yes. However, when it re-ran in August, they cut it down. I know. They trimmed out a bunch of stuff. Why was that? The reason this was originally a super-sized episode is because this was our 50th episode of The Office.
我喜欢它。好吧。那么，你准备好迎接第二个速记事实了吗？是的。第二个速记事实，这一集最初是在 2007 年 5 月播出的，它是一个超长集。是的。然而，当它在 8 月重播时，他们把它剪短了。我知道。他们剪掉了很多东西。为什么会这样？这一集最初是超长集的原因是这是我们的第 50 集《办公室》。
Oh, wow. So it was like a little celebration. But you know, then when shows rerun, they have to be regular size. Oh, I see. Well, to celebrate our 50th anniversary, we invited two superfan office bloggers to the set for a full day of filming so they could have a sneak piece. And do you remember who they were? Was it definitely Jenny Tan from Office Talley? Yes. And Kath Scary from Give Me My Remote. Oh, nice. Oh, they were so supportive of the show.
哦，哇。所以这就像一个小庆祝活动。但你知道，当节目重播时，它们必须是常规长度。哦，我明白了。为了庆祝我们的 50 周年，我们邀请了两位《办公室》的超级粉丝博主到片场进行全天的拍摄，这样她们就可以先睹为快。你还记得她们是谁吗？是来自 Office Tally 的珍妮·谭吗？是的。还有来自 Give Me My Remote 的凯丝·斯卡里。哦，不错。哦，她们非常支持这部剧。
I feel like they really were some of the first people organizing an online fan site where fans could go and share. Yeah, and the writers would read their sites and gather feedback, like they were a big part of formulating the show. I still go to office tally.com, Jenna. Like when I'm looking up quotes when we're doing our podcast document and I'm like, oh, I want to get that exactly right. I will go to office tally because they usually have quotes up there. Yeah. Well, I went and looked at both of their blogs that they did after visiting the set. And I'm going to sprinkle in some of their observations as we go along in this episode.
我觉得她们确实是第一批组织在线粉丝网站的人，粉丝们可以在那里去分享。是的，编剧们会阅读她们的网站并收集反馈，就像她们是构思这部剧的重要组成部分一样。我仍然会去 office tally.com，珍娜。就像我在做播客文档时查找引语，我想，哦，我想确保完全正确。我会去 Office Tally，因为她们通常有引语。是的。好吧，我看了她们参观片场后写的博客。随着这一集的进行，我会穿插一些她们的观察。
Oh, that's so fun. This is like a little time capsule. Yes, it was so cool. And by the way, okay, wait, here's one of the things. that Jenny Tan wrote about her visit. This was just sort of an overview. Okay. She wrote, everybody works together really well.
哦，那太有趣了。这就像一个时间胶囊。是的，太酷了。顺便说一句，好的，等等，这是其中一件事。珍妮·谭写了关于她访问的内容。这只是一个概述。好的。她写道，每个人合作得非常好。
The actors are just incredible, and they are so well prepared, knew their lines, and I didn't hear any of them once ask for a line. That's true, though. That's true. We were pros. We came up ready to play. But you know what? Steve set the bar for that.
演员们简直不可思议，他们准备得非常充分，知道自己的台词，我一次也没听到他们要求提示台词。那是真的。那是真的。我们是专业人士。我们准备好表演了。但你知道吗？史蒂夫为此设定了标准。
We've said that many times. She also probably couldn't see that we had our script. hidden in our desks, and we would sometimes have to sneak a look. We had to sneak a look between takes. We did do that. We did sort of like just look over them really quickly. But that's all right. That's all right.
我们已经说过很多次了。她可能也看不到我们把剧本藏在桌子里，我们有时不得不偷偷看一眼。我们不得不在拍摄间隙偷偷看一眼。我们确实那样做了。我们确实只是快速地看一眼。但没关系。没关系。
We were never like line. Can I get my line? What's my line? Yeah. So, yeah. And then Angela, another thing I thought was really interesting, she noted that you had a 4.30 a.m. call time that day. Those first few seasons, I was almost always at 4.30 because we didn't have.
我们从来没有像“台词。能给我台词吗？我的台词是什么？”那样。是的。所以，是的。然后安吉拉，另一件我觉得非常有趣的事情，她注意到你那天早上 4:30 就有通告时间。前几季，我几乎总是 4:30 到，因为我们没有
have, you know, the budget that we then ultimately gained and we hired more hair and makeup people. So they would stack us super early in the morning. Kate Flannery and I always were there at 4.30. I remember that. And then this also, I thought was kind of funny. She wrote this. Jenna mentioned more than once on her MySpace blog that she sometimes wears sweatpants and her ugs when she knows she's only being shot from the waist up and it's true. She wanted, she confirmed that I only got half dressed. set was so cold. I know. I know. So anyway, I am really excited because I'm going to sprinkle some of their observations in throughout the episode. All right. So what's
你知道，我们后来最终获得的预算，我们雇佣了更多的发型和化妆人员。所以他们会让我们在清晨排队。凯特·弗兰纳里和我总是 4:30 就在那里。我记得。然后这个，我也觉得挺好笑的。她写了这个。珍娜在她的 MySpace 博客上不止一次提到，当她知道自己只被拍到腰部以上时，她有时会穿运动裤和 UGG 靴子，这是真的。她想，她证实了我只穿了一半。片场太冷了。我知道。我知道。所以不管怎样，我真的很兴奋，因为我会在这一集里穿插一些她们的观察。好吧。那么
fast fact number three? Fast fact number three is a location breakdown based on this fan question from Deva Crane, Sophia Behenna, Cassandra Irichetta, Mary Ruff, and Jocelyn Isaguire. They all ask, did you film in a real mall? Where was it? Did you have to close it down? Or did you film with real patrons? Now, Ange, I usually go to Kentapedia. But you didn't need to this time, lady. You didn't need to because this was our mall. This was our mall, you guys. Literally, this is the mall in our neighborhood where we lived. Angela and I have been to this mall in real life 90 gazillion times. Many, many times together, separately.
第三个速记事实是什么？第三个速记事实是基于德瓦·克兰、索菲亚·贝赫纳、卡桑德拉·伊里切塔、玛丽·拉夫和乔斯林·伊萨吉雷提出的粉丝问题的地点解析。她们都问，你们是在真正的商场拍摄的吗？是在哪里？你们必须关闭它吗？还是你们和真正的顾客一起拍摄的？现在，安吉，我通常会去 Kentapedia。但你这次不需要，女士。你不需要，因为这是我们的商场。这是我们的商场，伙计们。字面上，这就是我们居住的社区里的商场。安吉拉和我已经在现实生活中去过这个商场 90 亿次了。很多，很多次，一起，分开。
Sometimes we'd have a BFF date. Yes. This was Fashion Square Mall in Studio City. It was like three miles from my house. Oh, yeah. We went all the time. We knew the layout. We knew when they said, okay, ladies, we're going to start the morning in the food court.
有时我们会进行闺蜜约会。是的。这是位于 Studio City 的 Fashion Square Mall。离我家只有三英里远。哦，是的。我们经常去。我们知道布局。我们知道当他们说，好的，女士们，我们早上要在美食广场开始。
You and I were like, I wonder where they're going to seat us. Maybe over by Panda Express, or are they going to put us over in the corner? I bet they put us in the corner. Yeah. We knew the layout. We knew the layout, of course. And guys, we did not close down the whole mall for filming. No.
你和我当时想，我想知道他们会把我们安排在哪里。也许在熊猫快餐旁边，或者他们会把我们放在角落里？我打赌他们会把我们放在角落里。是的。我们知道布局。我们知道布局，当然。伙计们，我们没有为了拍摄关闭整个商场。没有。
No, people were there. We started crazy early, though. In the food court. Yeah. And we started upstairs. There was like an upper level of the food court. And we had that whole upper level to ourselves. And it didn't open until like 11 a.m.
没有，人们在那里。不过我们开始得非常早。在美食广场。是的。我们从楼上开始。美食广场有一层上层。我们拥有整个上层。它直到上午 11 点才开放。
But we had to be done so they could open the food court on time. I remember that. Yeah. I wrote that we were seated in the, food court filming at 7 a.m. Yeah. Yes. And all the people in that food court were hired background performers. But later, when we went into the mall, all the people sort of passing behind us, like behind your talking head, behind Steve's talking head, those were just people in the mall. Yeah. They couldn't close that main part of the mall, right? So we were just
但我们必须在他们准时开放美食广场之前完成。我记得。是的。我写道，我们在上午 7 点坐在美食广场拍摄。是的。美食广场里的所有人都是雇来的背景演员。但后来，当我们进入商场时，所有从我们身后经过的人，比如在你谈话头镜头后面，在史蒂夫谈话头镜头后面，那些只是商场里的人。是的。他们不能关闭商场的主要部分，对吧？所以我们只是
navigating around them and we were filming. And that, this is a thing I wrote in my journal, Jenna, that we really realized what a big star Steve was. Like, we knew he had become a big star. You know, he had these movies coming out and they were big hits. But being at that shopping mall to him, we really got a window into what his life was like now because no one yelled our names. No one, Jenna, people are walking right past us. But they would see Steve and they would start to yell at him. Steve, Steve, I wrote that someone yelled, I love Lamp. Oh yeah, that line from Anchorman. Yes. And we were like, oh my God, Steve, that guy's yelling at you about the lamp. And he goes, I know. Yeah. Yeah. That was crazy. Yeah. That was crazy. I do remember, though, that they shut down the victorious secret for us. We had the whole store.
在他们周围穿行，我们在拍摄。而且，这是我在日记里写的一件事，珍娜，我们真正意识到史蒂夫是一个多么大的明星。就像，我们知道他已经成为了一颗大明星。你知道，他有这些电影上映，而且它们非常成功。但在那个购物中心对他来说，我们真正看到了他现在的生活是什么样的，因为没有人喊我们的名字。没有人，珍娜，人们直接从我们身边走过。但他们会看到史蒂夫，他们会开始对他大喊大叫。史蒂夫，史蒂夫，我写道有人喊，“我爱台灯”。哦，是的，来自《王牌播音员》的那句台词。是的。我们当时想，哦，天哪，史蒂夫，那个人在对你大喊关于台灯的事。他说，我知道。是的。是的。那太疯狂了。是的。那太疯狂了。不过我确实记得，他们为我们关闭了维多利亚的秘密。我们拥有整个商店。
Yeah, we felt very fancy about that. That was very exciting. To have a whole store to yourself. That was so cool. And then we also had one level of the parking garage. And they put all our trailers. there. We ate lunch there. They set up the catering. And then we also were able to bring in our own cars to do that scene with Meredith. Yeah. Parking. Yeah. But we really, we really just spent the whole day at the mall. We really did. We really did. And lady, by the way, I'm going to point it out, but there oftentimes, you can see you and I walking in the background together. Yeah. of different shots. And our characters should not be walking together in the background shopping.
是的，我们对此感到非常时髦。那非常令人兴奋。拥有整个商店给自己。那太酷了。然后我们还有一层停车场。他们把我们所有的拖车都放在那里。我们在那里吃午饭。他们设置了餐饮。然后我们还能够带上我们自己的车来拍摄梅雷迪斯的那场戏。是的。停车。是的。但我们真的，我们真的在商场待了一整天。我们真的待了。我们真的待了。而且女士，顺便说一句，我会指出来，但通常你可以看到你和我一起在背景中走动。是的。在不同的镜头里。我们的角色不应该在背景中一起购物。
No, we were just kind of, we were just hanging out. We were probably saying this, listen, we should come back tomorrow because did you see the sale? We were 100% doing that. We were Kelly at the mall. Yeah. If we have a break, maybe we can sneak in there. Yeah. I mean, I feel like we did some shopping that day.
没有，我们只是在闲逛。我们可能在说这个，听着，我们明天应该回来，因为你看到那个折扣了吗？我们 100% 在做那个。我们是商场的凯利。是的。如果我们有休息时间，也许我们可以溜进去。是的。我是说，我觉得那天我们确实买了一些东西。
I was going to say, I swear I came home with something from there. I know. I know. I'm pretty sure. All right. Well, ladies, should we take a break and then we come back, we will really, really break down this episode. I might have tracked something. We might need to discuss it. That is the best news I've heard all day. I can't wait to track something with you. You might change your mind. Oh, no. All right. We'll be back. episode is brought to by Tron Aries for the first time the captivating world of Tron breaks out of the grid. Aries, a highly advanced program, journeys into our world on a dangerous mission, marking humankind's first encounter with AI beings. Featuring an electrifying original soundtrack by 9-inch nails, Tron Aries is a must-see movie event, filmed for IMAX and made for the big screen.
我正想说，我发誓我从那里带回了什么东西。我知道。我知道。我很确定。好吧。那么，女士们，我们应该休息一下，然后回来，我们将真正地、真正地解析这一集。我可能追踪到了什么。我们可能需要讨论一下。这是我今天听到的最好的消息。我等不及要和你一起追踪什么了。你可能会改变主意。哦，不。好吧。我们会回来的。本集由 Tron Aries 赞助，这是迷人的 Tron 世界第一次冲出网格。Aries，一个高度先进的程序，踏上了一段危险的旅程进入我们的世界，标志着人类与 AI 存在的第一次接触。Tron Aries 拥有由九寸钉乐队创作的震撼原创配乐，是一部必看的电影盛事，为 IMAX 拍摄，为大银幕而生。
Experience it only in theaters Friday. Get tickets now. And we are back. We start with a cold open, Jenna, that was originally written for the Business School episode. What? Yes, the Cold Open, where Jim comes in and he's tardy, and Dwight is going to write him up. That was originally for the Business School episode, and the Dwight and Jim, dressing like each other, was supposed to be for this episode. But they switched them for time. Wow.
仅在周五影院体验。现在就买票。我们回来了。我们从一个冷开场开始，珍娜，它最初是为“商学院”那一集写的。什么？是的，冷开场，吉姆进来迟到了，德怀特要写报告。那最初是为“商学院”那一集写的，而德怀特和吉姆互相打扮成对方，应该是为这一集写的。但他们为了时间交换了它们。哇。
Yeah. Well, you know, they would do these cold open. opens, and they were meant to be standalone. They were meant to be their own encapsulated joke that really didn't interfere with the main plot of an episode. So I guess they were kind of interchangeable in a way. Now, sometimes the cold open did affect the plot, but, you know, two stand-alone cold opens, I guess you can put them wherever you want.
是的。好吧，你知道，他们会做这些冷开场，它们旨在成为独立的。它们旨在成为它们自己封装的笑话，并没有真正干扰一集的主要情节。所以我猜它们在某种程度上是可以互换的。现在，有时冷开场确实影响了情节，但是，你知道，两个独立的冷开场，我想你可以把它们放在任何你想放的地方。
And I feel like the tag in this episode is plot related, so I think it was for the best. Yes, I agree. All right. So, Jenna, here's the thing. Do you know that if you are tardy, you will get three demerits? Yep. And then you'll receive a citation. Yeah.
我觉得这一集的标签与情节有关，所以我认为这是最好的。是的，我同意。好吧。那么，珍娜，事情是这样的。你知道如果你迟到，你会得到三个扣分吗？是的。然后你会收到一张传票。是的。
Yeah. And then five citations and you're going to get a violation. Which is bad because tell us what happens after that. Four violations and you're going to get a verbal warning. Oh, no. Yeah. Keep it up. You're going to get a written warning.
是的。然后五张传票，你就会得到一个违规。这很糟糕，因为告诉我们那之后会发生什么。四次违规，你就会得到一个口头警告。哦，不。是的。继续保持。你会得到一个书面警告。
Yeah. Two written warnings. And you're going to be in a world of hurt in the form of a disciplinary review. And that disciplinary review is going to be written by Dwight and placed on the desk of his immediate superior, who, by the way, is Jim? Who is tardy? Right. It's going to take a week worth of, like, paperwork.
是的。两次书面警告。你就会陷入麻烦，形式是纪律审查。而那个纪律审查将由德怀特写出，并放在他的直属上司的桌子上，顺便说一句，是吉姆？谁迟到了？对。这需要一周的文书工作。
I mean, this just made me laugh so hard. I just feel like I know these people. I feel like I know a Dwight. I feel like I worked with a Dwight. Like someone who has such a small amount of control and takes it so seriously. It's just so ridiculously perfect. I love it. This episode opens with Phyllis Arrive,
我是说，这让我笑得太厉害了。我只是觉得我认识这些人。我觉得我认识一个德怀特。我觉得我和一个德怀特一起工作过。就像一个拥有如此少控制权却如此认真对待的人。这太荒谬地完美了。我喜欢它。这一集以菲利斯到达
to work and she is clearly upset. And by the way, I really like how all of us are genuinely kind to Phyllis and concerned for her. Yeah. Yeah, she's shucking up and we're worried about her. And Jenna, before we get into the scene, I have to share something with you that has become part of our family. It's like a family story. You know those stories in your family that you retell over and over. Yeah. Well, this episode inspired one of those family stories for me that we get together and retail at family reunions and everyone just cracks up. What is it? All right, Jenna, you know my grandmother, Lena May Kinsey. She was a very, very proper, classy, Southern lady. And, you know, she was not a fan of the office. She thought that Michael Scott was
工作开始，她显然很心烦。顺便说一句，我真的很喜欢我们所有人对菲利斯都很友善，并且关心她。是的。是的，她很震惊，我们为她担心。珍娜，在我们进入场景之前，我必须和你分享一件已经成为我们家庭一部分的事情。这就像一个家庭故事。你知道你家里那些你一遍又一遍重述的故事。是的。好吧，这一集为我激发了其中一个家庭故事，我们聚在一起在家庭聚会上重述，每个人都笑得前仰后合。是什么？好吧，珍娜，你知道我的祖母，莉娜·梅·金赛。她是一位非常、非常得体、优雅的南方女士。而且，你知道，她不是《办公室》的粉丝。她认为迈克尔·斯科特是
vulgar. And she would say to me, Angela, we are so proud of you. But I don't care for it. And I do not watch it. But we are so proud of you. I remember. So my parents were really getting into the show. And they were like, Lena May, you got to give it another shot. We gave it another shot. And now we like it. You got to watch this week's episode. Oh, no. I call home. I'm like, hey, mom, are you going to watch this week? We are. And we told your grandmother to watch. We got it on right now. I said, oh, no, mom, not this week. Not this week for grandmother. oh no she was like why not and I said because Phyllis gets flashed and it's all we talk about what did your grandma say when she watched this episode well she never watched another episode did she
粗俗的。她会对我这样说，安吉拉，我们为你感到骄傲。但我不喜欢它。我不看它。但我们为你感到骄傲。我记得。所以我的父母真的很喜欢这部剧。他们说，莉娜·梅，你得再给它一次机会。我们给了它一次机会。现在我们喜欢它。你得看这周的剧集。哦，不。我打电话回家。我说，嘿，妈妈，你们这周要看吗？我们要看。我们告诉你的祖母看了。我们现在就看。我说，哦，不，妈妈，这周不行。这周不适合祖母。哦，不，她说为什么不行，我说因为菲利斯被暴露狂骚扰了，这是我们谈论的全部内容。你祖母看这一集时说了什么？好吧，她再也没看另一集了，对吧？
I called home the next day and I said hey mom did you talk to grandmother did she watch it she said I did and this is what she said and I wrote it down and I have it my journal this is what my grandmother said I watched it right up until they started talking about penises and then I turned it off. That was probably good she turned it off because, I mean, we didn't want her to be subjected to that scene in the mall when Michael describes his sex life with jam. Oh my God. When he's like, what is a pap smear? I'm glad my grandmother didn't make it that far. Do you want to know when she turned it off? Yes. Four minutes, 25 seconds is the first time we say the word penis. click, bye-bye.
我第二天打电话回家，我说，嘿，妈妈，你和祖母谈了吗？她看了吗？她说我看了，这就是她说的，我把它写下来了，我有它在我的日记里，这就是我祖母说的：我一直看到他们开始谈论阴茎，然后我就把它关了。她把它关了可能很好，因为，我是说，我们不想让她在商场里看到迈克尔描述他与简的性生活的那一幕。天哪。当他说，什么是巴氏涂片？我很高兴我祖母没看到那么远。你想知道她什么时候关掉的吗？是的。4 分 25 秒是我们第一次说“阴茎”这个词。点击，再见。
She checked out. She was done. And I mean, up until that point, you know, we're talking about how Phyllis has been flashed and where he put it on the map. Oh, my God, Jenna, do you remember that Phyllis could not get through that? Do you remember that? No. Which part? She broke. Every time she said he had it out on the map.
她退出了。她完成了。我是说，在那之前，你知道，我们正在谈论菲利斯是如何被暴露狂骚扰的，以及他在地图上把它放在哪里。天哪，珍娜，你记得菲利斯无法完成那个吗？你记得吗？没有。哪一部分？她崩溃了。每次她说“他在地图上把它拿出来了”。
She could not get through it. She was laughing so hard. Well, I remember it was very difficult to get through. Creed saying, what's the big deal? He's hanging brain. That like, that phrase hanging brain was really tough. It's so gross. It's so gross. But then Michael comes in and he finds out what happens and he is like completely not sympathetic at all. And Phyllis isn't even there anymore. Phyllis has gone off with Bob Vance. He's taking her for a walk to calm her down. But Michael comes in and he is just making a joke of it.
她无法完成它。她笑得太厉害了。好吧，我记得很难完成它。克里德说，“有什么大不了的？他在挂脑子。”那句“挂脑子”真的很难。太恶心了。太恶心了。但后来迈克尔进来了，他发现了发生了什么，他完全不表示同情。菲利斯甚至不在那里了。菲利斯和鲍勃·万斯一起走了。他带她去散步让她冷静下来。但迈克尔进来了，他只是拿它开玩笑。
And he puts his finger in his pants, through the zipper of his pants, to look like a penis. And I remember we all thought, there's no way this is making this on TV. Well, Jenna, I was super curious about how we were able to get this on the air. So I went to the DVD commentary to see if they said anything. And they did say there was one specific thing we had to do by standards and practices rules. Oh, really? This went all the way to standards and practices. Should we tell them what standards and practices is? Yeah, well, there's like, there's certain rules about what you can and cannot broadcast on network television. Well, according to the DVD commentary, this was the one thing
他把手指伸进裤子里，穿过裤子的拉链，看起来像个阴茎。我记得我们都认为，这不可能在电视上播出。好吧，珍娜，我非常好奇我们是如何让它播出的。所以我去了 DVD 评论，看看他们是否说了什么。他们确实说有一件具体的事情我们必须按照标准与实践规则去做。哦，真的吗？这一直传到了标准与实践部门。我们应该告诉他们什么是标准与实践吗？是的，好吧，有一些关于你可以在网络电视上广播什么和不能广播什么的规则。好吧，根据 DVD 评论，这是唯一的一件事
we had to do by standards and practices. Before Michael turns around with his finger and his, the fly of his pants? Yeah. Camera has to see him fully extend his hand outside of his pants and then watch his hand go in his pants through his fly. So you know beyond a shadow of a doubt, that is Michael's hand. You'll see Michael turns around and you have a close-up of his hand and what, and he's kind of fidgeting so that we all know it's his hand. And that was because standards and practices said that's the only way we'll let the scene play. Wow. I know. I still can't believe that we got away with it. And then what I really can't believe is that when Toby walks in, the finger goes down. Yes. Well, fan catch from Breanne, Catherine, Julie, Elizabeth, and Christina. Everyone noticed that in the background of this exchange between Michael and Toby, it's sort of near the end after Toby's walked away and Michael is apologizing.
我们必须按照标准与实践去做。在迈克尔转过身用他的手指和他的裤子拉链之前？是的。摄像机必须看到他完全把手伸出裤子，然后看着他的手通过拉链进入裤子。所以你知道毫无疑问，那是迈克尔的手。你会看到迈克尔转过身，你有一个他手的特写，什么，他有点烦躁，这样我们都知道那是他的手。这是因为标准与实践说这是我们让场景播放的唯一方式。哇。我知道。我仍然不敢相信我们逃脱了惩罚。然后我真正不敢相信的是，当托比走进来时，手指就放下了。是的。好吧，来自布里安、凯瑟琳、朱莉、伊丽莎白和克里斯蒂娜的粉丝捕捉。每个人都注意到在迈克尔和托比之间的这段交流的背景中，在托比走开后，迈克尔道歉时，
John Krasinski is visibly red in the face and laughing into his hand. He is flat out breaking. And not only that, I love this fan catch because I wrote a time code down between four minutes and 36 seconds and four minutes 40 seconds, I see John, not Jim, look right to Randall, our camera operator. Yes, I thought the same thing. I thought that is not Jim glancing to camera. That is John glancing at Randall. Yes, because it's just above camera. You know, it's not right down the barrel,
约翰·卡拉辛斯基脸红了，对着手笑。他完全崩溃了。不仅如此，我喜欢这个粉丝捕捉，因为我写下了一个时间码，在 4 分 36 秒到 4 分 40 秒之间，我看到约翰，不是吉姆，直接看着兰德尔，我们的摄像师。是的，我想的一样。我想那不是吉姆瞥向摄像机。那是约翰瞥向兰德尔。是的，因为它就在摄像机上方。你知道，它不是直接对着镜头，
which is where he would normally glance. He's looking at Randall trying not to break. And Randall was probably breaking too, but they're having a moment. And the line that really made him go is when Michael says, as that was coming out of my mouth, I knew that it was wrong. Well, now Michael has a talking head
那是他通常会瞥向的地方。他看着兰德尔试图不崩溃。兰德尔可能也崩溃了，但他们有一个时刻。真正让他崩溃的台词是当迈克尔说，“当那从我嘴里说出来时，我就知道它是错的。”好吧，现在迈克尔有一个谈话头镜头
where he explains that in all of the excitement, he forgot that his primary concern is keeping the people in his office safe and that women just can't have fun if they don't feel safe. And he knows this because, you know, he and Jan have a safe word, which is foliage. What is happening in that bedroom? I don't know. What is happening that he has a safe word that she doesn't pay attention to? What is happening?
他解释说，在所有的兴奋中，他忘记了他主要关心的是确保办公室里的人安全，如果女性感到不安全，她们就无法玩得开心。他知道这一点，因为，你知道，他和简有一个安全词，是“叶子”。卧室里发生了什么？我不知道。发生了什么让他有一个简不注意的安全词？发生了什么？
I don't know. Oh, Lord. Oh, and then Jan's phone call, she, like, once his body, she's going to leave him $200, $300, she'll get more vodka. Hunter, are you on the call? Like, everything about this is horrifying. Lady, I have to say that that thing of, like, Hunter, are you on the call? That has happened to me in business calls where I'll be talking to my agent or to my manager, and I'm having what I think is like a private, candid conversation. And all of a sudden, like 20 minutes in, they'll ask their assistant, did you get that? Can you go ahead and set that meeting? And the assistant's like, no problem. I'll put it in the calendar.
我不知道。哦，天哪。哦，然后简的电话，她，就像，想要他的身体，她要给他 200 美元，300 美元，她会买更多的伏特加。亨特，你在通话中吗？就像，关于这个的一切都是可怕的。女士，我必须说，像“亨特，你在通话中吗？”那样的事情，在我商务通话中发生过，我会和我的经纪人或经理交谈，我正在进行我认为是私人的、坦诚的谈话。突然，20 分钟后，他们会问他们的助理，“你得到了吗？你能继续安排那个会议吗？”助理说，“没问题。我会把它放进日历里。”
And I'm like, wait, what? How long have you put in the thing? You just, your assistant just listens to our phone calls. That's a thing. Man, oh man, I couldn't be an assistant. I couldn't handle that information. It would be so hard for me not to interject. Like if I had to listen in and my boss was having a comment.
我当时想，等等，什么？你把那个东西放进去多久了？你只是，你的助理只是听我们的电话。那是一件事。天哪，我不能成为助理。我处理不了那个信息。如果我必须听着，而我的老板有一个评论，我很难不插嘴。
conversation with someone and it got like sort of personal or heated, it'd be so hard for me, you know, to not be like, you know, you might try. Just take in a minute, take a breath before you, you know, don't say something you're going to regret. They'd be like, who is that? Well, we have a nice callback at five minutes, 47 seconds. Yes, we had some fans catch this as well, Angela. Dwight is down in the parking lot and he is stabbing the shrubbery. with that pointed, carved-out broom handle that he made for business school when he was worried that Jim was becoming a vampire. Yeah, he kept it. Of course he kept it. He probably duct taped it under his desk. Well, that was caught also by Renee Brown and Stevens, Bethany A, Phoebe Tomac, and Jacob Hirsch, among others.
和某人谈话，如果变得有点私人化或激烈，对我来说真的很难，你知道，不去……你可能会尝试。在你说出让自己后悔的话之前，先花一分钟，深呼吸一下。他们会说，那是谁？好吧，我们在5分47秒有一个很好的回溯。是的，安吉拉，我们也有一些粉丝注意到了这一点。德怀特在停车场，他正在用那个尖尖的、雕刻过的扫帚柄刺灌木丛，那是他在商学院时做的，当时他担心吉姆会变成吸血鬼。是的，他留着它。他当然留着它。他可能把它用胶带粘在桌子底下了。好吧，蕾妮·布朗、史蒂文斯、贝瑟尼·A、菲比·托马克和雅各布·赫什等人也注意到了这一点。
All right. So, Jenna, now it's six minutes, 29 seconds. Michael and Dwight have decided they are going to form a new anti-flashing task force. They come out and announce this, and I want you to know, Rain Wilson broke so hard throughout this scene. Jenna, I think we did like 15 or 16 takes. Do you remember what line he could not get through because I will never forget it? I'll never forget it. And it's on the bloopers.
好的。那么，珍娜，现在是6分29秒。迈克尔和德怀特决定成立一个新的反暴露狂特别工作组。他们出来宣布了这件事，我想让你知道，雷恩·威尔逊在这一整场戏里笑场得太厉害了。珍娜，我想我们拍了大概15或16次。你还记得他哪句台词说不出来吗？因为我永远不会忘记。我永远不会忘记。而且它在花絮里。
Oh. It's so good. Say it, Jenna. So he says that we should install floodlights in the parking lot. Yeah. And then he says, I know, I know what you're thinking. Won't that just shed more light on the penises? We could not get through that line.
哦。太棒了。说出来，珍娜。所以他说我们应该在停车场安装泛光灯。是的。然后他说，我知道，我知道你在想什么。那不是会照亮那些阴茎吗？我们没法把那句台词说完。
When I was rewatching and I heard him say it again. Yeah. I was like, we could, that line is so genius and absurd. I know. Sorry, it just cracks me up. And all of it, all of it was so perfect. And then him having to say, Pam, you can draw, get with fallas. You're like, Phallus?
当我重看的时候，我又听他说了一遍。是的。我就想，我们可以，那句台词太天才、太荒谬了。我知道。抱歉，它总是让我笑个不停。而且这一切，这一切都太完美了。然后他不得不说，帕姆，你会画画，和菲利斯（Phallus）一起。你就像，菲利斯（Phallus）？
Phyllis, sorry, I just have penises on the brain. And then Jim's look to camera. This whole moment is just so beautifully written and performed. Yes. And the other thing that led to the absurdity of it is that you're expecting Dwight to have horrible ideas, but his ideas start off really good. Smart. This idea of floodlights, this idea of extra security cameras. And I remember being directed to give a look to Phyllis, like reassuring like, hey, they're not going to totally mess this up. And then it just gets weird and
菲利斯（Phyllis），抱歉，我脑子里全是阴茎。然后是吉姆看向镜头的眼神。整个这一刻写得和演得都太美了。是的。而导致这种荒谬感的另一件事是，你预料德怀特会有糟糕的主意，但他的主意一开始真的很好。很聪明。这个泛光灯的主意，这个额外安全摄像头的主意。我记得当时导演让我给菲利斯一个眼神，就像安慰一样，嘿，他们不会把事情搞砸的。然后事情就变得奇怪了，而且
so funny. Yeah. He starts out so well. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Well, So Pam is going to meet up with Phyllis, and she's going to make a sketch, except that Phyllis can't really remember any details. And Pam's like, it's fine. I just don't feel like answering the phone. Yeah. But then Karen enters, and now we get Dwight's weird list of ideas. So, like, what he was announcing originally is what the business park was planning to do to help the situation. And now we're getting Dwight's mandate.
太搞笑了。是的。他开始得很好。是的。天哪。好吧，所以帕姆要和菲利斯见面，她要画一张草图，但菲利斯记不起任何细节。帕姆说，没关系。我只是不想接电话。是的。但随后凯伦进来了，现在我们有了德怀特那些奇怪的主意清单。所以，他最初宣布的是商业园区计划采取的措施，以帮助解决这种情况。而现在我们得到的是德怀特的指令。
Yeah, Dwight's mandate is basically. lock up the women. And get rid of all the bananas. Yeah. What is happening? Yes. He starts saying that like the women have to dress a certain way. They have to wear sleeves down to their wrists, muted colors.
是的，德怀特的指令基本上是。把女人们锁起来。然后把所有的香蕉都扔掉。是的。发生了什么？是的。他开始说女人们必须以某种方式着装。她们必须穿袖子到手腕的衣服，颜色要柔和。
And Pam is like no one dresses like that. And then the camera swings over to Angela, which is a very funny moment. That was in the script. I remember this was one of those moments, Jenna, that it looks simple, but it was very choreographed because the B camera had to find me and zoom in, right? And it's a quick, it's a very quick whip over and it had to, you know, be in focus. So that's a really tiny moment, but it was very thought out exactly where I would stand and it was all timed off of your line. And I want you to know, since we're talking about what I have on, that at eight
帕姆说没人那样穿。然后镜头转向安吉拉，这是一个非常有趣的时刻。那是在剧本里的。我记得这是那些时刻之一，珍娜，看起来很简单，但编排得很精细，因为B摄像机必须找到我并放大，对吧？这是一个快速的，非常快速的横摇，而且必须，你知道，对焦。所以那是一个非常小的时刻，但它经过深思熟虑，确切地知道我会站在哪里，而且完全是根据你的台词来计时的。我想让你知道，既然我们在谈论我穿的衣服，在8
minutes, 28 seconds is when you see my outfit that our wardrobe designer carry Bennett and I had so much fun. We were giddy. When she got the script and it said I would be wearing this like cat sweater and this outfit, we just couldn't wait. And I tried on all these different sweaters. This is the one we picked. And you can't really tell, but each of the cat is very different and distinct. And one of the cats on the sweater had a beaded purse that it was carrying. Wow. One of the other cats had like earmuffs, but the earmuffs were like poofy. you know? Wow. Yeah. I wish I still had that sweater. I talked to Carrie about where did she shop for you? Where did she find this stuff? And you know what she told me? What? She said that a lot of
分28秒时，你看到了我的服装，我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特和我玩得很开心。我们当时很兴奋。当她拿到剧本，上面写着我会穿这件猫咪毛衣和这套衣服时，我们简直等不及了。我试穿了所有不同的毛衣。这是我们选中的那件。你看不出来，但每一只猫都非常不同且独特。毛衣上的一只猫还背着一个珠饰钱包。哇。另一只猫戴着耳罩，但耳罩是蓬松的，你知道吗？哇。是的。我真希望我还留着那件毛衣。我问过凯莉她是在哪里为你买的？她在哪里找到这些东西的？你知道她告诉了我什么吗？什么？她说很多
your sweaters and your fluffy blouses were vintage. That's true. That is true. And there was no double for them. There was just one. Yeah. And it would make her a little nervous because if you spilled coffee on it or something, she was going to be in trouble. But that was how she found these weird little items. And also, she said vintage clothing usually run smaller. And so it was fewer alterations for her, actually. Yes, that is true. And she would let me know when whatever sweater or blouse I had didn't have a double. And I always made sure, Jenna, to change at lunch. I never ate in my clothes because we often didn't have a match for it. I remember that. I also remember you, sometimes, Angela, if we were rushing, you would do this really elaborate, like, napkin bib thing on the front of you.
你的毛衣和蓬松衬衫都是复古的。那是真的。那是真的。而且它们没有替身。只有一件。是的。这会让她有点紧张，因为如果你把咖啡洒在上面什么的，她会有麻烦的。但这就是她找到这些奇怪小物件的方式。而且，她说复古服装通常尺码较小。所以实际上对她来说修改得更少。是的，那是真的。她会告诉我我穿的哪件毛衣或衬衫没有替身。我总是确保，珍娜，在午餐时换掉。我从不在穿这些衣服时吃饭，因为我们通常没有备用的。我记得那个。我还记得你，有时候，安吉拉，如果我们很赶时间，你会做那种非常复杂的，像餐巾纸围兜一样的东西在你的胸前。
I would take, I would take, sometimes we were rushing for whatever reason and I didn't have time to run to my trailer and change. I would get, like, eight napkins and tuck them around my collar all the way to my armpit. Yeah. I looked insane. So now the women in the office, they're really upset. with Dwight, right? These rules are ridiculous. And Michael comes out. He's upset with Dwight. He's like, you know what? Women's appreciating meeting in the conference room. He's qualified to appreciate women. Because he came from a woman. Yeah. He has slept with more than one woman. Less than three.
我会拿，我会拿，有时候我们因为某种原因很赶时间，我没时间跑回我的拖车去换衣服。我会拿大概八张餐巾纸，把它们塞在我的领口周围，一直塞到腋下。是的。我看起来疯了。所以现在办公室里的女人们，她们真的很生德怀特的气，对吧？这些规则太荒谬了。迈克尔出来了。他对德怀特很生气。他说，你知道吗？女性欣赏会议在会议室举行。他有资格欣赏女性。因为他来自一个女人。是的。他和不止一个女人睡过。少于三个。
Well, that's not accurate information. Yeah. He says. Yeah. But also, he just knows the crap out of women, Angela. I know. What women need is R-E-S-P-C-T. That's what they need. Phyllis' face when he says that is so amazing. She gets this little look that washes over her face like, huh? Fan question from Taylor, Seagraves and Jenna Aldridge. When Michael spells out respect, was that improv or scripted? It was scripted that he spelled it out correctly and then every take he would do it differently. couldn't get through it. This was another moment. That's what Steve would do, though. You know, he was like the comedy assassin. He would like take it as it was written and then he would play around with it. You could never know what he was going to do and it made it so hard to keep a straight
好吧，那不是准确的信息。是的。他说。是的。但同时，他只是非常了解女性，安吉拉。我知道。女性需要的是R-E-S-P-E-C-T（尊重）。这就是她们需要的。当他说出那个词时，菲利斯的表情太棒了。她脸上掠过那种小表情，好像，哈？来自泰勒、西格雷夫斯和珍娜·奥尔德里奇的粉丝提问。当迈克尔拼出尊重时，那是即兴发挥还是剧本写的？剧本写的是他正确地拼了出来，然后每次拍摄他都会做得不一样。没法拍完。这是另一个时刻。不过这就是史蒂夫会做的事。你知道，他就像喜剧刺客。他会按照剧本写的那样，然后他会玩弄它。你永远不知道他会做什么，这让人很难保持严肃
face. Yes. Also during this scene, Angela Dwight is eating a banana. Yeah. And this is one of the ones he's taken from the kitchen. Kath from Give Me My Remote.com noted in her blog that Rain had to eat a new banana every time we started over a new take. And we did a lot of takes of this scene. She asked Rain on set that day how it was to eat all the bananas. And he said it was making him sick and he may never eat another banana again. It turned on him.
的表情。是的。在这场戏中，安吉拉，德怀特正在吃香蕉。是的。这是他从厨房拿走的其中一个。来自GiveMeMyRemote.com的凯丝在她的博客中指出，雷恩每次开始新拍摄时都必须吃一根新香蕉。我们拍了很多次这场戏。那天她在片场问雷恩吃这么多香蕉感觉如何。他说这让他感到恶心，他可能再也不想吃香蕉了。它让他反胃了。
That would happen. Yeah. And he made a big choice early on, which was to devise. the banana, which was a very, very funny choice. And he had to repeat it then. But that is how he made Dwight eat. Rain, you did this to yourself. Let's not forget the pancakes. And then we have a candy bar coming up. Dwight does nothing half-assed. If he's going to eat something, he eats it. Yeah. That's true. Sorry, I'm yelling at you. I like it. Bring it on. I'm getting very worked up by how Dwight eat.
那会发生的。是的。而且他很早就做了一个重大选择，那就是设计吃香蕉的方式，这是一个非常、非常有趣的选择。然后他不得不重复它。但这就是他让德怀特吃东西的方式。雷恩，这是你自己造成的。别忘了煎饼。然后我们接下来还有一个糖果棒。德怀特从不半途而废。如果他要吃什么，他就会吃完。是的。那是真的。抱歉，我在对你大喊大叫。我喜欢这样。来吧。德怀特吃东西的方式让我非常激动。
Well, now the meeting is underway in the conference room. Michael is perched on his chair, like a bird. Nine minutes, 36 seconds. How does Steve sit like this? I don't know. How does he do it? He just finds the most awkward ways to sit and stand, and it's so funny. Well, he apologizes for all of the men who didn't take this seriously.
好吧，现在会议在会议室开始了。迈克尔像只鸟一样栖息在他的椅子上。9分36秒。史蒂夫是怎么这样坐的？我不知道。他是怎么做到的？他总是能找到最尴尬的坐姿和站姿，这太搞笑了。好吧，他为所有没有认真对待这件事的男人们道歉。
Creed still doesn't understand. what the big deal is, but Michael explains no one likes being flashed. It's not just women. When Meredith flashed him during the Christmas party, he was sick. He hated it. Yeah. But listen, he also wants us to know that a penis in the right context is the most wonderful sight for a woman. But in the wrong context, it's like a monster movie. I have a question for you. When Dwight goes, alien, blah. And Michael's like, shut it, shut up. Was that improvised? Oh, my God. I don't know. Do you want me to look it up? I do, because I remember Rain, as Dwight, messing around. And I just didn't know if that was him being an idiot. And it got to stay in. Well, let me see. How should I find this in this document? I'm thinking I should put in the word penis.
克里德仍然不明白这有什么大不了的，但迈克尔解释说没人喜欢被暴露狂骚扰。不仅仅是女性。当梅雷迪思在圣诞派对上向他暴露时，他感到恶心。他讨厌那样。是的。但听着，他还想让我们知道，在正确的语境下，阴茎对女性来说是最美妙的景象。但在错误的语境下，它就像一部怪物电影。我有一个问题要问你。当德怀特说，外星人，等等。然后迈克尔说，闭嘴，闭嘴。那是即兴发挥吗？哦，天哪。我不知道。你想让我查一下吗？我想，因为我记得雷恩，作为德怀特，在胡闹。我只是不知道那是他在装傻。而且它被保留了下来。好吧，让我看看。我该怎么在这个文档里找到这个？我想我应该输入阴茎这个词。
Oh, God. And see. Oh, there's so many. I so many oh boy I'm opening up some snacks your grandma would not have liked this word search right now no oh all right okay I found it so after Michael said that Dwight was supposed to say Freddie Kruger okay I remember this I remember that rain kept doing these alts that he was kind of making up in the moment and that alien one was not one that was scripted. I was pretty sure, but I wanted to see. You were right. This is a random tangent. Okay. Have you ever been flashed? Well, I've spent a lot of time in New York City, and I've seen a lot of penises on the street and on the subway. Oh, my Lord. But I've never been directly flashed. What about you? Oh, I mean, listen, women out there listening,
哦，天哪。看看。哦，有这么多。我这么多，哦，天哪，我正在打开一些零食，你奶奶可能不会喜欢现在的这个词搜索，不，哦，好吧，好的，我找到了。所以迈克尔说那句话之后，德怀特本应该说弗莱迪·克鲁格，好的，我记得这个，我记得雷恩一直在做这些他在那一刻即兴创作的替代台词，而那个外星人的台词不是剧本写的。我很确定，但我还是想看看。你是对的。这是一个随机的题外话。好的。你曾经被暴露狂骚扰过吗？好吧，我在纽约市待过很长时间，我在街上和地铁上见过很多阴茎。哦，天哪。但我从未被直接暴露过。你呢？哦，我是说，听着，正在听的女士们，
they're just creepers and it I mean I have been flashed one I was waiting for the tube in London I was in college and doing a semester abroad and my friend and I were standing there and this old man I'm talking in his 70s it was like if you saw it in a movie you'd be like oh it's too on the nose he literally had on a khaki trench coat he was 70 oh And he opened up his trench coat and was totally naked and wiggled around his old man penis. And we were like, oh my God! It was so crazy to me because it looked like something out of a cartoon. I was like, this can't be real.
她们只是变态，我是说我确实被暴露过一次，我在伦敦等地铁，我在上大学，在国外做交换生，我和我的朋友站在那里，这个老头，我是说70多岁了，就像如果你在电影里看到它，你会说，哦，这太刻意了，他真的穿着一件卡其色的风衣，他70岁了，哦，他打开了他的风衣，完全赤裸，摇晃着他老人的阴茎。我们当时想，哦，天哪！这对我来说太疯狂了，因为它看起来像卡通片里的东西。我想，这不可能是真的。
Old dude, khaki coat, flasher, and a subway, come on. You know, flashing is considered a sexual assault. And statistically, many young and underage women, that is. is their sort of first experience with a sexual assault is flashing, is men flashing their penises. And it's horrible. It's freaking horrible. I was young so I just went, ah. And then years later, I was flashed and I literally yelled, knock it off. But why do we have to deal with that? I don't know. Why do women have to deal with that? Like, I don't have enough to do in my day. I also have to tell you not to flash me.
老家伙，卡其色外套，暴露狂，在地铁里，得了吧。你知道，暴露被认为是性侵犯。从统计学上讲，许多年轻和未成年女性，那是她们第一次经历性侵犯就是暴露，是男人暴露他们的阴茎。这太可怕了。这太可怕了。我当时很年轻，所以我只是啊了一声。然后多年后，我又被暴露了，我真的大喊，住手。但为什么我们必须处理这种事？我不知道。为什么女性必须处理这种事？就像，我一天中要做的事情还不够多吗？我还得告诉你不要向我暴露。
Yeah. I have to tell you to get your penis out of my face. I'm busy. I don't have time for that shit. I don't have time for your old man penis. No, I don't. For real. You know what I mean?
是的。我得告诉你把你的阴茎从我面前拿开。我很忙。我没时间处理那种破事。我没时间处理你那老人的阴茎。不，我没有。说真的。你知道我的意思吗？
My grandmother would have turned us off, Jenna. This podcast. I feel like your grandma would be on my side on this one. Oh, for sure. I'd like your grandma and I to go around and talk to some flashers Oh, she would let them have it Well, let's see
你奶奶会把我们关掉的，珍娜。这个播客。我觉得你奶奶在这件事上会站在我这边。哦，肯定的。我希望你奶奶和我能到处走走，和一些暴露狂谈谈，哦，她会让他们好看的，好吧，让我们看看
Sorry, I got us off on a tangent But I was just like, hey, I've been flashed, I wonder if Jenna has. Most women have been flashed. That's the problem. Yep. And you know what, by the way, I just want to say the unsolicited Dick Pick text is the modern day flashing.
抱歉，我让我们跑题了，但我只是想，嘿，我被暴露过，我想知道珍娜有没有。大多数女性都被暴露过。这就是问题所在。是的。顺便说一句，我只想说，未经请求的阴茎照片短信是现代的暴露。
Oh, yes. If a woman doesn't ask to see your dick, don't send a pick. Yeah. It's not difficult. Yeah. Truly. Truly.
哦，是的。如果一个女人没有要求看你的阴茎，就不要发照片。是的。这并不难。是的。真的。真的。
It's like, why does it need to be said? Oh my God. You got me all amped up. I'm sorry. I just am realizing I've never gotten a dick pick. What? Honestly, I've never gotten a dick pick either. We're old, we're old, but...
就像，为什么需要说出来呢？哦，天哪。你让我太兴奋了。抱歉。我只是意识到我从来没收到过阴茎照片。什么？老实说，我也从来没收到过阴茎照片。我们老了，我们老了，但是……
We've been flashed. We haven't had dickpick. But young ladies. these get dick picks. Okay. Where were we? Where we are is that Michael is angry at society. He says that the problem is that the media portrays women as being skinny, tall goddesses,
我们被暴露过。我们没收到过阴茎照片。但年轻女士们，她们会收到阴茎照片。好的。我们刚才说到哪了？我们现在说到迈克尔对社会很生气。他说问题在于媒体把女性描绘成瘦高个的女神，
which if you look around the office, they clearly are not in real life. Yeah. You know, even the prettiest ones are, what does he say? Not that thin or something. Yeah. Jennifer, you're just like, hey, what the heck? No, people ask us that all the time if we were personally offended by jokes at our expense. And no, I don't know, is it just because in comedy you're so often asked to be self-deprecating or you just have a good sense of humor?
如果你环顾办公室，她们在现实生活中显然不是那样。是的。你知道，即使是最漂亮的那些，他说什么来着？没那么瘦什么的。是的。珍妮弗，你就像，嘿，搞什么鬼？不，人们总是问我们是否对以我们为代价的笑话感到个人冒犯。不，我不知道，是不是因为在喜剧中你经常被要求自嘲，或者你只是有很好的幽默感？
I don't know. I thought it was funny. Yeah, I mean, same with me. I'm always like some size joke, you know. And it also just never really felt personal. I don't know. It didn't. The joke is that he's saying something he shouldn't say, right? Yeah. Well, Karen tells Michael he's being misogynistic, and Michael is like, thank you. Thank you.
我不知道。我觉得这很有趣。是的，我是说我也是。我总是像某种身材笑话，你知道。而且它也从来没有真正感觉是针对个人的。我不知道。没有。笑话是他说了他不该说的话，对吧？是的。好吧，凯伦告诉迈克尔他有厌女症，迈克尔说，谢谢。谢谢。
Yes. And she's like, no, I'm saying you're being sexist. He's like, no, I'm not. I'm being misogynistic. And she's like, oh, my God. And then the women just start to really call him out. Phyllis is like, Michael, when I got my haircut short, you said I look like a lesbian. And Angela's like, yeah, and you always think we're on our periods if we get upset.
是的。她说，不，我是说你很性别歧视。他说，不，我没有。我有厌女症。她说，哦，天哪。然后女人们就开始真正地指责他。菲利斯说，迈克尔，当我剪短发时，你说我看起来像个女同性恋。安吉拉说，是的，而且如果我们心烦意乱，你总是认为我们处于经期。
But that's because he needs to know if he should take you seriously or not. I know. There's a lot of issues. There's a lot of issues. Well, Karen and Angela want to get back to work, but Michael says he knows what the problem is. The problem is they're in too masculine of an environment to really bond and heal. He needs to take them to the mall. Yeah.
但那是因为他需要知道他是否应该认真对待你。我知道。有很多问题。有很多问题。好吧，凯伦和安吉拉想回去工作，但迈克尔说他知道问题出在哪里。问题在于她们所处的环境太男性化了，无法真正建立联系和治愈。他需要带她们去商场。是的。
He needs to take the women to a place where they can heal. And that's a shopping mall. Yes. We see a series of talking heads. Karen, she still thinks all of this idea of going to the malls insulting, but she had some items to return. I have a talking head that I say that malls are just awful and humiliating. They're just store after store of these horrible salespeople making a big fuss out of an adult shopping in a junior section. And I improvised the last line of this talking head. You did? I did. I said, there are petite adults who are sort of smaller who know. need to wear maybe a kid-sized tin. Lady, I've been to Target with you and gone shopping. Yeah. And you shop in the junior section.
他需要带女人们去一个她们可以治愈的地方。那就是购物中心。是的。我们看到了一系列访谈。凯伦，她仍然认为去商场的所有这些主意都是侮辱性的，但她有一些东西要退货。我有一个访谈，我说商场简直太糟糕了，太丢人了。它们只是一家又一家可怕的销售员，让一个成年人在青少年区购物变得大惊小怪。我即兴发挥了这段访谈的最后一句台词。你做了？我做了。我说，有一些娇小的成年人，比较瘦小的，可能需要穿童装尺码。女士，我和你去过塔吉特百货购物。是的。而且你在青少年区购物。
I do. I shop in the kids section. And for a long time, I was a kid-sized tin. I remember you couldn't find a pair of jeans that didn't have like a rainbow applique on the pocket. Yeah. All your clothes. All my clothes had a butterfly or something on it.
我确实。我在童装区购物。很长一段时间里，我都是童装尺码。我记得你找不到一条口袋上没有彩虹贴花的牛仔裤。是的。你所有的衣服。我所有的衣服上都有蝴蝶什么的。
I am no longer a kid-sized tin. Well, there you go. Okay, so Pam has now finished her sketch of the flasher and hands it over to Dwight. Yes, and he is thrilled. She's like, listen, Phyllis got a good look. This is accurate. Dwight starts making copies of this flyer, which reads, This man is a pervert, and the picture is very clearly Dwight with no glasses and a mustache.
我不再是童装尺码了。好吧，给你。好的，所以帕姆现在完成了她画的暴露狂草图，并把它交给了德怀特。是的，他很激动。她说，听着，菲利斯看得很清楚。这是准确的。德怀特开始复印这张传单，上面写着，这个人是个变态，照片非常清楚地显示是没戴眼镜、留着胡子的德怀特。
Lady, I saved one of these. flyers from that week. And I have it. I have the original, one of the original ones that Rain is holding up as Dwight. And I love it. It makes me laugh. I have it in my scrapbook, Ben. Speaking of, I've started scrapbooking. I saw on your Instagram stories. You put your kids to work on that. They were very excited. They loved it. It made me happy. I think it's a great idea. Well, listen, if you look on this poster, there is a phone number, a 1-800 number for the anti-flashing task force. This was a real phone number. Yes.
女士，我保存了一张那周的传单。我有它。我有雷恩作为德怀特举着的那张原件之一。我喜欢它。它让我发笑。我把它放在我的剪贴簿里，本。说到这个，我开始做剪贴簿了。我在你的Instagram故事里看到了。你让你孩子做那个。他们非常兴奋。他们很喜欢。这让我很高兴。我觉得这是个好主意。好吧，听着，如果你看这张海报，上面有一个电话号码，一个反暴露狂特别工作组的1-800号码。这是一个真实的电话号码。是的。
And after the episode, you could call it and you would get a message from Dwight. And I have what the message said. I love this. Read it, Jenna. You have reached Dwight K. Shrewt, commander of the Lackawanna County, Anti-Flashing Task Force and Regional Manager of Dunder Mifflin. If you have information leading to the capture and or castration of this pervert, press one. If this is the flasher, let's talk. You need a friend right now and I can help you.
在这一集之后，你可以拨打它，你会听到德怀特的一条留言。我喜欢这个。读出来，珍娜。你已经联系到了德怀特·K·舒鲁特，拉卡瓦纳县反暴露狂特别工作组指挥官兼邓德·米夫林地区经理。如果你有导致抓获和/或阉割这个变态的信息，请按1。如果这是暴露狂，我们谈谈。你现在需要一个朋友，我可以帮你。
Just tell me where you want to meet and I promise to help you with whatever it is you need. Thank you and have a nice day. Oh, and if you are inquiring about any of our paper products and would like a catalog, please press two. Finally, if anyone, not the flasher, is interested in a kick-ass 1985 maroon firebird, I could be persuaded to sell mine. Please press one for that, too. And people called it. A lot of people called that number. Here's an interesting trivia tidbit.
只要告诉我你想在哪里见面，我保证帮你解决你需要的一切。谢谢，祝你有美好的一天。哦，如果你想询问我们的任何纸制品并想要目录，请按2。最后，如果任何人，不是暴露狂，对一辆超酷的1985年栗色火鸟感兴趣，我可以被说服卖掉我的。请也按1。人们确实打了那个电话。很多人打了那个号码。这是一个有趣的琐事。
That is the same phone number as Vance Refrigeration. Oh, yes. Yes, when we've seen the Vance Refrigeration phone number. Yep. Well, listen, lady, before we head out to the mall, maybe we should take a break. Let's take a break because then we're getting into Meredith's van, and we're going to need to talk about it. Yeah. What a run.
那是万斯制冷公司的同一个电话号码。哦，是的。是的，当我们看到万斯制冷公司的电话号码时。是的。好吧，听着，女士，在我们去商场之前，也许我们应该休息一下。让我们休息一下，因为接下来我们要进入梅雷迪思的货车，我们需要谈谈它。是的。多么棒的旅程。
This champ is picking up speed. But they found a lane. Phenomenal launch into the air. Absolutely incredible air trans-hats. Fly the seven-time world's best leisure airline champions, Air Transat. Okay, we are back and all the ladies are off to the mall with Michael in Meredith's really fantastic van. Yeah, she's driving, but also eating potato chips and littering. I do want you all to know that we had a van following behind us, and their job was to pick up the bag.
这个冠军正在加速。但他们找到了一条车道。向空中发射的非凡表现。绝对令人难以置信的空中跨大西洋航班。乘坐七次世界最佳休闲航空公司冠军，跨大西洋航空。好的，我们回来了，所有的女士们都和迈克尔一起坐梅雷迪思那辆非常棒的货车去商场了。是的，她在开车，但也在吃薯片和乱扔垃圾。我确实想让你们都知道，我们后面跟着一辆货车，他们的工作是捡起那个袋子。
It would go out the car, and they had to pick up. pick up the bag, so we, in fact, did not litter. That is incredible. Yeah. We had a fan question about the van from Nikki Lawrence. How did they decide the order in which you all sat in Meredith's van? Was it planned out or did you just sit wherever? Well, I know that I sat in the front seat because I get car sick and I know that they planned it that way, but I went to the script and here is what it said about the van.
它会从车里扔出来，他们必须捡起。捡起那个袋子，所以我们实际上并没有乱扔垃圾。那太不可思议了。是的。我们有一个来自尼基·劳伦斯的关于货车的粉丝提问。他们是如何决定你们所有人坐在梅雷迪思货车里的顺序的？是计划好的还是你们只是随便坐？好吧，我知道我坐在前排，因为我晕车，我知道他们是那样计划的，但我查了剧本，这是关于货车的描述。
Okay. It said, the van is strewn with. take-out containers, and the dashboard is lit with every warning light imaginable. Michael sits in the middle seat of the middle row between Kelly and Phyllis. Karen and Angela are in the back row. Michael watches the girls talk as if he's Jane Goodall observing apes. That was the script direction for our van placement. So it was planned.
好的。上面写着，货车里散落着外卖容器，仪表盘上亮着所有能想象到的警告灯。迈克尔坐在中间一排的中间座位，在凯利和菲利斯之间。凯伦和安吉拉在后排。迈克尔看着女人们交谈，就像珍·古道尔观察猿类一样。那是我们货车座位的剧本指导。所以这是计划好的。
But lady, when I read this, you can't see it. in the episode, but do you remember how filthy the inside of that van was? Jenna, it was so crazy. The props department went all out. You could not see the floorboard. That's how much stuff they threw into that van. It literally looked like someone had lived in there for years. There were takeout containers. There were like food items that had been half eaten are made to look half eaten. Sitting next to me in the seat was a half-eaten chocolate chip cookie on the seat next to me. And when we would get in, we would step and kind of turn our ankles on all these weird things.
但女士，当我读到这个时，你看不出来。在这一集里，但你还记得那辆货车里面有多脏吗？珍娜，太疯狂了。道具部门全力以赴。你看不见地板。他们往那辆货车里扔了多少东西。它看起来简直就像有人在那里住了好几年。到处都是外卖容器。有一些食物看起来像是吃了一半，或者被做成吃了一半的样子。坐在我旁边的座位上有一个吃了一半的巧克力曲奇。当我们进去时，我们会踩到这些奇怪的东西，扭伤脚踝。
Pieces of clothing, like a broken, like old phone, like just everything you could imagine. It looked like someone dumped a trash can in the floorboard. Well, another thing they did, and I don't know if you remember this, Ange, but as a a joke, they thought it would be really funny if they put all of these air fresheners in the front of her car. So like Meredith wouldn't clean out her car, she would just add another air freshener and they were dangling from the rearview mirror. They were all over the dashboard. Yes, they were all over the front of the car. Just the front where Kate and I were sitting and the fumes from these air fresheners were making us sick. You were getting a headache
衣服碎片，像坏掉的，像旧手机，就像你能想象到的一切。看起来就像有人把垃圾桶倒在地板上。好吧，他们做的另一件事，我不知道你是否记得这个，安吉，但作为一个笑话，他们认为如果他们在她的车前放上所有这些空气清新剂会非常有趣。所以梅雷迪思不会清理她的车，她只会再加一个空气清新剂，它们从后视镜上垂下来。它们到处都是，在仪表盘上。是的，它们在车前到处都是。就在凯特和我坐的地方，这些空气清新剂的烟雾让我们感到恶心。你当时头痛
And you kept being like, gosh, guys, I keep getting a headache, you know, while we were filming in the van. I was in the way back with half-eaten food. I couldn't smell the air fresheners. I remember there was all of a sudden this moment where you and Kate were like, oh, my God, it's these air fresheners. There's like 15 of them. And here's the thing. You couldn't even see them. So they were like, oh, we don't even see those in the shot.
你一直说，天哪，伙计们，我一直头痛，你知道，当我们坐在货车里拍摄时。我坐在最后面，有吃了一半的食物。我闻不到空气清新剂的味道。我记得突然有那么一刻，你和凯特说，哦，天哪，是这些空气清新剂。有大概15个。事情是这样的。你甚至看不见它们。所以他们说，哦，我们甚至在镜头里看不到那些。
We can just take those out. So they took them out. And then we were fine. It's too bad you couldn't see the hard work that the crew did to make that van look so junky inside. Yeah. It was a work of art. Jenna, there's one thing in the DVD commentary about the scene where Meredith is eating the potato chips. Like, she just dumps them on her face from the bag and throws the bag out.
我们可以把它们拿出来。所以他们把它们拿出来了。然后我们就没事了。太可惜了，你没看到剧组为了让那辆货车里面看起来那么破烂所做的努力。是的。那是一件艺术品。珍娜，DVD评论里有一件事是关于梅雷迪思吃薯片的场景。就像，她只是把它们从袋子里倒在脸上，然后把袋子扔掉。
In the DVD commentary, you said you kept laughing and laughing and laughing. You couldn't keep a straight face. and they actually used a different reaction shot of you from a different moment in the van because they never got a clean one of you. I was probably jealous too because I really like those sour cream and onion chips. You do love sour cream and onion.
在DVD评论里，你说你一直在笑，一直在笑。你无法保持严肃的表情。他们实际上使用了你从货车里不同时刻的另一个反应镜头，因为他们从来没有得到一个干净的镜头。我可能也嫉妒，因为我真的很喜欢那些酸奶油洋葱味的薯片。你确实喜欢酸奶油洋葱味。
You and my daughter. Isabel loves them. I do too. I can't keep them in the house. It'll just be cheddar bunnies all over again. Oh, no. So now we're back at Dunder Mifflin. And this is such a quirky,
你和我女儿一样。伊莎贝尔喜欢它们。我也喜欢。我不能把它们放在家里。那又会变成切达干酪小兔子饼干了。哦，不。所以现在我们回到邓德·米夫林了。这是一个非常古怪的，
little storyline where Kevin comes up to gym and says, would you like to join me in the women's bathroom? I thought this was so funny because I just so believe this curiosity of like, what's it like on the other side over there? You know? I mean, I've been in a men's room and like, it's disgusting. Disgusting. So gross. Like I've been like somewhere like a Starbucks, like a year ago or so. And there's a line for the women's room. And like I, my daughter really, really had to go. And there was no one in the men's room. So I was like, listen, we'll just go quickly. And you go in the men's room and it's like, ugh, what is going on in there?
小故事线，凯文走到吉姆面前说，你想和我一起去女厕所吗？我觉得这太搞笑了，因为我非常相信这种好奇心，就像，那边另一边是什么样的？你知道？我是说，我去过男厕所，就像，太恶心了。恶心。太恶心了。就像我大概一年前在星巴克之类的地方。女厕所排着队。而且，我女儿真的，真的必须去。男厕所里没人。所以我说，听着，我们很快就进去。你走进男厕所，就像，呃，里面发生了什么？
Another thing I'd like to say is that, you know, there are a lot of fathers with daughters and they are actively parenting their children and they go places and their kids need to use the bathroom. And by the way, their little boys need to sit down too. Can we keep our bathrooms clean guys? Can we keep them a little cleaner so that dads can. take their kids to the bathroom, and it's not totally disgusting. Jenna is just asking two things, guys.
我想说的另一件事是，你知道，有很多带着女儿的父亲，他们积极地抚养他们的孩子，他们去一些地方，他们的孩子需要上厕所。顺便说一句，他们的小男孩也需要坐下来。我们能保持我们的厕所干净吗，伙计们？我们能让它们稍微干净一点，这样爸爸们就能带他们的孩子去上厕所，而且不会完全恶心吗？珍娜只是在问两件事，伙计们。
No dick picks. No, unsolicited. Unless, if a lady asks for your dick pick, send away. Go for it. Fire away. Far away. I don't know why that's making me laugh. But yeah, and keep your toilets tidy.
没有阴茎照片。不，未经请求的。除非，如果一位女士要求看你的阴茎照片，那就发吧。去吧。开火。远去。我不知道为什么这让我发笑。但是是的，保持你的厕所整洁。
So yes, Kevin is curious. He wants to go in the women's room, and he goes in. He's like, oh, my God, you got to see this. There's like a sofa. There's potpourri. There's candles. There's like a nice lamp, you know, magazines. Do you blame us?
所以是的，凯文很好奇。他想进女厕所，然后他进去了。他说，哦，天哪，你一定要看看这个。有沙发。有干花。有蜡烛。有像样的灯，你知道，杂志。你怪我们吗？
This is our only sanctuary away from Michael. We've had to do this in this office. It's the one place he cannot come speak to us. So we've created, I believe, a sanctuary. Oh, yeah. Well, I have to tell you, this. bathroom, the woman's bathroom set, this is a non-working bathroom. None of the sinks and toilets actually worked when we weren't using them. I was always bummed about that, by the way.
这是我们远离迈克尔的唯一避难所。我们不得不在这个办公室里这样做。这是他不能来和我们说话的唯一地方。所以我相信，我们创造了一个避难所。哦，是的。好吧，我必须告诉你，这个厕所，女厕所的布景，这是一个不能工作的厕所。当我们不使用它们时，所有的水槽和马桶实际上都不能工作。顺便说一句，我总是为此感到沮丧。
Because they were so conveniently located to our set, but they weren't real. The actual bathrooms were much further away, and I always wished our fake toilets and sinks worked. You know, they used to put signs on the toilets, warning visitors that they were fake and not hooked up to any plumbing. Yes, and I feel like those signs were made because someone, didn't know. They had to deal with that moment. They did. Yuck. That's true. A visitor used our fake toilet. Can you imagine if you're a big fan of the office and you get to come to set and get a tour and you're just giddy, you're so happy to see all these characters that you love, and you're the visitor that took a dump in the fake
因为它们离我们的布景太方便了，但它们不是真的。真正的厕所在更远的地方，我总是希望我们假的马桶和水槽能工作。你知道，他们过去常在马桶上贴标志，警告游客它们是假的，没有连接任何管道。是的，我觉得那些标志是因为有人，不知道。他们不得不处理那个时刻。他们确实。恶心。那是真的。一个游客用了我们的假马桶。你能想象如果你是办公室的忠实粉丝，你有机会来到片场参观，你非常兴奋，你很高兴看到所有你喜欢的角色，而你就是那个在片场假马桶里拉屎的游客。那个人是谁？那个人知道他们是谁？这就是为什么我们必须制作标志并把马桶封起来。哦，天哪。好的，抱歉。好吧，我也想说，厕所在这一集之前看起来不是这样的。他们不得不搭建这个小布景。他们确实。我是说，几乎这些假厕所真的很小。
toilet on set. Who was that person? That person knows who they are? And that's why we had to make signs and tape up the toilets. Oh, my God. Okay, sorry. Well, also, I want to say that the bathroom didn't look like this before this episode. They had to build this little set. They did. I mean, pretty much these fake bathrooms were really small.
当它们不被使用时，它们是储藏室。它们就像壁橱。是的，剧组会把他们的支架、灯光和东西放在那些厕所门后面。是的。好吧，他们在厕所里的这场戏，他们只是在闲聊，吉姆说他要和凯伦去吃晚餐庆祝六个月纪念日。我有一个问题。我们庆祝我们约会六个月纪念日吗？我们在做那个吗？
And when they weren't being used, they were storage. They were like closets. Yeah, the crew would keep, like, their stands and lights and things behind those bathroom doors. Yeah. Well, this scene that they have in the bathroom, they're kind of just chit-chatting, and Jim says that he's going out to dinner for his six-month anniversary with Karen. And I have a question. Do we celebrate our six-month anniversary of dating? Are we doing that?
我觉得如果事情进展不顺利，你会庆祝。我刚才就是想说那个。是的。当你需要庆祝什么时，你会标记你们约会六个月纪念日的场合，因为这很困难。是的，因为你会想，我们坚持了六个月，这对她来说意义重大。所以让我们庆祝一下。我有同样的想法。我在这一场戏里笑得不行，因为瑞安显然不知道什么是干花。他要吃它吗？他在玩它。他在坐立不安。而且这也很尴尬。他给凯伦发了这封电子邮件，吉姆说，是的，她读了
I think you do if things aren't going well. That's what I was going to say. Yeah. You mark the occasion of your six-month dating anniversary when you need something to. celebrate because it's been difficult. Yeah, because you're like, we made it six months and this will mean a lot to her. So let's celebrate it. I had that same thought. I was cracking up in the scene because Ryan clearly doesn't know what potpourri is. Is he going to eat it? He's playing with it. He's fidgeting. And it's also awkward. He sent Karen this email and Jim's like, yes, she read it
给我听。这太令人尴尬了，而且做得太好了。但我忍不住看着BJ玩弄那些干花。我同意。好吧，回到商场，梅雷迪思正在停货车，她只是撞到了旁边的车。珍娜，在DVD评论里，他们说，我们真的那样做了。我们真的，真的刮坏了一辆真正的车。不，不是我们不拥有的。不，我们拥有它，但仍然，他们本来要看看他们是否能作弊，看起来真的很紧。但是，但是你不能作弊那个镜头。然后只是加入音效什么的。是的，他们本来要加入音效，看看我们是否能作弊。但你不能。你看得太清楚了。所以他们只是让凯特真的那样做了。凯特·弗兰纳里，没有特技司机，挤进那辆货车并刮坏了那辆车。然后我们不得不支付赔偿金。是的。但那是我们的车。它就像一辆作为我们道具车的拍摄车。好吧，当我们进入商场时，我们在美食广场。你记得，女士，当时大概是早上7点。
to me. It's so cringy and just so well done. But I couldn't help but watch BJ playing with that popery. I agree. Well, back at the mall, Meredith is parking the van, and she is just just crashing into a car next to her. Jenna, in the DVD commentary, they said, we really did that. We really, really scraped up an actual car. No, not one that we didn't own. No, we owned it, but still, they were going to see if they could cheat it, where it looked really tight. But, but you can't cheat that shot. And just put in like a sound effect or something. Yes, they were going to put in a sound effect and see if maybe we could just cheat. But you couldn't. You could see it too clearly. So they just let Kate actually do that. Kate Flannery, there was no stunt driver, wedged that van and scraped up that car. And then we had to pay for the damages. Yeah. But it was our car. It was like a picture car as our sort of prop car. Well, when we get into the mall, were up in the food court. And you remember, lady, it was like 7 a.m.
是的。而且我，太早了。我刚看了这场戏。你谈到瑞安玩干花。我只是看着这一幕，对拉什达在早上7点坚持吃那些薯片印象深刻。我当时想，你行。我记得真的很希望我们有苏打水。就像，我当时想，哦，我愿意为了一瓶可口可乐什么的付出一切，因为它太早了。
Yeah. And I, it was so early. And I just watched this scene. You talk about Ryan playing with the potpourri. And I was just watching this being so impressed that Rashida committed to eating those chips at 7 a.m. I was like, you go. I remember really wishing we had soda. Like, I was like, oh, I'd give anything for a Coca-Cola or something because it was so early.
但那些杯子里只有水。我当时想，哦，该死，我需要一些咖啡因。我记得非常嫉妒明迪的肉桂卷。是的。而且我一直在读《电力城》，那是一份真正的斯克兰顿报纸。是的。好吧，我也想指出，在这一场戏中，迈克尔说，女士们，让我们聊聊你们脑子里的任何事。然后我数了一下，有15秒的沉默时刻。
but those cups just had water in them. And I was like, oh, dang it, I could use some caffeine. I remember being very jealous of Mindy's Cinnabon. Yes. And I'm just reading the Electric City the whole time, which is an actual Scranton newspaper. Yes. Well, I also want to note that in this scene, Michael says, ladies, let's dish about anything on your mind. And then I counted, there is a 15 second moment of silence.
我喜欢那个。我喜欢我们的节目那样做。我知道。他打破了沉默，问什么是巴氏涂片。还有，是涂片吗？嗯。作为一个年轻女性成长过程中，我不清楚是涂片还是涂片。我不知道。
I love that. I love when our show does that. I know. And he breaks the silence by asking what a PAP smear is. And then also, is it smear? Mm-hmm. Growing up as a young woman, it was a little unclear to me if it was smear or smear. I had no idea.
是涂片。巴氏涂片。巴氏涂片。是的，约瑟夫，如果这一直在困扰其他人，它不是像百吉饼上的奶油奶酪那样的涂片。是的。
It's smear. Papp smear. Pap smear Yeah Joseph and if this has been haunting anyone else It is not smear like the cream cheese On a bagel Yeah
他们涂抹它。好的。在他们巴氏涂片之后。那是对的。帕姆把话题转到了凯利和瑞安身上。但这并没有什么进展。然后迈克尔开始问她们关于角色扮演的事。这就是他
They smear it Okay After they pap it That's right Pam changes the subject to Kelly and Ryan But that doesn't really go anywhere And then Michael starts asking them about role play And this is when he
我想。很明显他和简玩角色扮演。他扮演女学生。但显然，菲利斯也玩。菲利斯，就像，是的，这很有趣。菲利斯非常，她当然不反对这个主意。不，她说。
I guess It becomes clear that he and Jan do roleplay Where he is the school girl But also apparently So does Phyllis. Phyllis, like, yeah, it can be fun. Phyllis is very, she's certainly not disapproving of the idea. No, she said.
然而，安吉拉说，我离开这里。我要去玩偶店。是的。她说，我不需要坐在这里听迈克尔谈论他和简的性生活。我走了。是的。现在，安吉拉，接下来有一个大场景，然后你不在里面。你在做什么？
Angela, however, is like, I'm out of here. I'm going to the doll store. Yeah. She's like, I don't need to sit here and listen to Michael talk about his sex life with Jan. I'm out. Yeah. Now, Angela, there is a big scene coming up now and then you're not in it. What were you doing?
你只是回你的拖车了吗？我有点记得坐在椒盐卷饼店旁边，像安妮阿姨那样的椒盐卷饼店。我以为那是韦策尔的椒盐卷饼。是安妮阿姨的吗？是其中之一。
Were you just back in your trailer? I kind of remember sitting by the the pretzel place, the anti-Anns like pretzel place. I thought it was a Wetzel's pretzel. Is it an anti-ans? It's one of those.
好吧，在这一场戏中，我们让迈克尔列出他和简在一起的利弊清单。他的一个弊端是，我和她在一起时不快乐。我们都帮他听到了这一点。对吧？或者像，迈克尔。
Well, in this scene, we ask Michael to make a list of pros and cons for why he is with Jan. And one of his cons is, I'm not happy when I'm with her. And we all kind of like help him hear that. Right? Or like, Michael.
我觉得你应该和简分手。他不确定。菲利斯说，别想了。你想做什么？迈克尔说，我想和简分手。我想和简分手。是的。我是说，我觉得这就像菲利斯有的一个很棒的小时刻。我做过这样的事。珍娜，你没有吗？你没有吗？你没有过那种时刻，就像你对某事有很多感觉，你正试图理清它们。你只是想，好的，让我的头脑安静下来。这让我感觉如何？如果我在做决定时遇到困难，这可能是一件大事或小事。我会拿出一枚硬币，让它成为一件小事。让我们就像我想买这个新沙发。好的。但我无法决定。好的。
I think you should break up with Jan. And he's not sure. And Phyllis is like, no thinking. What do you want to do? And Michael says, I want to break up with Jan. I want to break up with Jan. Yeah. I mean, I feel like this is like a great little moment that Phyllis has. And I've done stuff like this. Jenna, haven't you? Haven't you? Haven't you like had a moment where you're like, you have a lot of feelings about something and you're trying to make sense of them. And you just are like, okay, quiet my mind. How does this make me feel? If I'm having a hard time making a decision, it could be a big thing or a small thing. I'll get out a coin and let's make it a small thing. Let's be like I want to buy this new couch. Okay. But I can't decide. Okay.
我觉得你应该和简分手。他还不确定。菲利斯说，别想了。你想怎么做？迈克尔说，我想和简分手。我想和简分手。是的。我的意思是，我觉得这是菲利斯一个很棒的小时刻。我也做过类似的事情。珍娜，你没有吗？你没有吗？你难道没有过那种时刻吗，就是你对某件事有很多感受，正在努力理清它们。然后你只是想，好吧，让我的心静下来。这让我有什么感觉？如果我在做决定时遇到困难，无论是大事还是小事。我会拿出一枚硬币，把它变成一件小事。比如我想买这个新沙发。好吧。但我无法决定。好吧。
So heads is by the couch and tails is don't buy the couch. I don't let the coin decide, but what I do is I flip it. Yeah. And then I note my reaction to the answer. because usually you kind of do care yes or no so if I flip it and it says no don't buy the couch and I feel relieved then I have my answer but if it says no don't buy the couch and I'm disappointed and I'm like oh two out of three that means I want to buy the couch right did that make sense it does make sense I feel like I always know I always know pretty much how I feel
正面朝上就是买沙发，反面朝上就是不买。我不会真的让硬币来决定，但我会抛它。是的。然后我会留意自己对结果的反应。因为通常你心里其实是有倾向的，所以如果我抛硬币，结果显示不买沙发，而我感到如释重负，那我就知道答案了；但如果结果显示不买，我却感到失望，心想“三局两胜”，那就意味着我想买沙发，对吧？这说得通吗？确实说得通，我觉得我总是很清楚自己当下的感受。
about something in the moment. I don't have to like break down how I feel about it. It's very clear to me. It's easy for you to make decisions? Yes. Even with breakups and relationships? Well, here's the thing about relationships. Sometimes you know, but it takes you a while before you can say it out loud because of the ramifications. Right. But I think you always know. Well, I think the women really help Michael know and he is very excited and to thank them for helping him he's going to buy each one of them an item from Victoria's Secret. It's what we all wanted. Yeah. And then there is a talking head that Lee Eisenberg, the writer of this episode said, is one of his favorite things he got to write for Steve because Steve's delivery is so great. It's the one where he says most guys want
我不需要去剖析自己的感受。这对我来说很明确。你做决定很容易吗？是的。即使是在分手和感情问题上？嗯，感情问题是这样的。有时候你心里清楚，但因为后果严重，你需要一段时间才能说出口。没错。但我认为你心里总是清楚的。嗯，我觉得这些女士们确实帮迈克尔认清了现实，他非常兴奋，为了感谢她们的帮助，他打算给每个人买一件维多利亚的秘密的商品。这正是我们所有人想要的。是的。然后有一个采访镜头，这集的编剧李·艾森伯格说，这是他为史蒂夫写的最喜欢的片段之一，因为史蒂夫的演绎太棒了。就是他说大多数男人想要
there women and high heels with cleavage and wearing skimpy little outfits. I'm paraphrasing, obviously, but that he thinks a woman looks best absolutely naked. He just said when he heard Steve deliver the end of that talking head, he so nailed it. It was like, it was like a gymnast sticking the landing. Yeah, totally. Well, Jenna, here's one quick thing. There are deleted. scenes for this episode. And there's some really great ones, but one that I found sort of curious and fun is that all the women go into the Victoria Secrets except for Pam and Angela. They hang back outside in the mall. And there's a beat where you and I look at each other and we don't really say anything and we're like, ah, I guess. And then we both walk in.
他们的女人穿高跟鞋、露乳沟、穿暴露的小衣服。我显然是在转述，但他认为女人最美的样子是完全赤裸。他说当他听到史蒂夫说出那段采访的结尾时，他演得太到位了。就像体操运动员稳稳落地一样。是的，完全同意。对了，珍娜，有一件小事。这一集有删减片段。有一些非常棒的片段，但我发现其中一个挺有趣且好奇的是，所有的女士都进了维多利亚的秘密，除了帕姆和安吉拉。她们留在商场外面。有一个瞬间，你和我对视了一眼，我们什么也没说，就像是“啊，好吧”。然后我们俩都走了进去。
Well, that's very interesting because we had a fan catch from Sophia Lee. And this. This is one of those moments, Ange, at 20 minutes, 10 seconds, you and I are way back in the background of Steve's talking head and we're just walking together through Victoria's Secret. I feel like we didn't know we were on camera and we're just shopping. We were just sort of being chatty in the background. Totally. That tracks. Should we go back to the ladies lounge at Dunder Mifflin? Yes.
嗯，这很有趣，因为我们收到了粉丝索菲亚·李的发现。在20分10秒的时候，安吉，你和我在史蒂夫采访镜头的背景里，我们正一起走过维多利亚的秘密。我觉得我们当时不知道自己在镜头里，只是在逛街。我们在背景里闲聊。确实。这很符合逻辑。我们要回到邓德·米夫林的女士休息室吗？好的。
And I have one of my favorite lines from this episode. and it's Toby and Paul Lieberstein totally crushes it. Kevin's like, we should do this more often, guys. This is great. And Toby goes, I think we hang out an appropriate amount of time. Yeah. It's so good. It's so good.
我这一集最喜欢的台词之一出现了，是托比说的，保罗·利伯斯坦演得太棒了。凯文说：“伙计们，我们应该多聚聚。这太棒了。”托比说：“我觉得我们聚在一起的时间已经够多了。”是的。太棒了。真的太棒了。
And then at 20 minutes, 35 seconds, we have a major old tech alert when Creed enters the bathroom with a walkman. With a yellow waterproof walkman. remember those? I owned one. I owned one. I owned one. They were the best. Do you remember the little gray buttons though would pop off? Yep. Yep. Yep. And you'd have to wedge them back in. But it was fun. And why did we need a waterproof Walkman? Well, the idea was that you were going to get so sweaty while you were working out. But I mean, really? Okay. Well, I guess also Brian Baumgartner told me that when Creed would enter the bathroom with that Walkman and be completely stunned and horrified that other people were in there, it would make everyone crack up and they had a really, really hard time just getting
然后在20分35秒，当克里德带着随身听走进洗手间时，我们迎来了一个重大的老科技警报。带着一个黄色的防水随身听。还记得那些吗？我有一个。我也有一个。我也有一个。它们是最好的。你还记得那些容易掉下来的灰色小按钮吗？记得。记得。记得。你得把它们塞回去。但那很有趣。为什么我们需要防水随身听？嗯，当时的想法是你锻炼时会出很多汗。但说真的？好吧。嗯，我想布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳也告诉我，当克里德带着那个随身听走进洗手间，发现里面有人而感到完全震惊和惊恐时，这会让每个人都笑喷，他们真的很难做到
that, just getting Creed in the room. They could not get Creed in. I loved Creed's talking head, too, because he's listening to music while he's doing the talking head. So he's sort of like yelling over the music he's listening to. Yes. And I think it's pretty on brand that Creed would go poo in the women's restroom. You know those people, Jenna. You know those people. We've had roommates. The roommate that goes and takes a dump in your bathroom instead of theirs, that's Creed.
就是让克里德进入房间。他们无法让克里德进去。我也很喜欢克里德的采访镜头，因为他在做采访时还在听音乐。所以他是在对着音乐大喊大叫。是的。而且我觉得克里德会在女厕所大便非常符合他的人设。你知道那种人，珍娜。你知道那种人。我们有过室友。那种不去自己的洗手间，非要跑去你洗手间拉屎的室友，那就是克里德。
Well, now, and we go back to the mall, Angela and Michael are sitting, and I love the scene so much. Michael is dying for Angela to pick something out that he can buy her. He has a line where he says, can I please buy you some underwear? Yeah. So you guys, Steve wanted me to break. He was 100% messing with me. And I'd been given a very strict note from Tucker Gates and Lee and Gene that they really did not want Angela to entertain him at all. So I had to sit there very stoic as Steve as Michael just got to throw these lines at me.
好了，现在我们回到商场，安吉拉和迈克尔坐着，我非常喜欢这一幕。迈克尔渴望安吉拉挑一件他能买给她的东西。他有一句台词说：“我能给你买些内衣吗？”是的。所以你们知道吗，史蒂夫想让我笑场。他百分之百是在捉弄我。塔克·盖茨、李和吉恩给了我一个非常严格的指示，他们真的不希望安吉拉配合他。所以我必须坐在那里表现得非常冷漠，而史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔则不断地对我抛出这些台词。
And there's a few in the bloopers because it was really hard to keep it together. And Steve was just having a great time. I watched the bloopers for this. And there is a great line that didn't make it. Is it because I started laughing? Yeah. But Steve went on to improvise something along the lines of like, pretend it's Christmas and I'm Santa. Santa would like to buy you some panties.
花絮里有几个片段，因为真的很难忍住不笑。史蒂夫玩得很开心。我看了这一集的拍摄花絮。有一个很棒的台词没用上。是因为我笑场了吗？是的。但史蒂夫即兴发挥了一些类似“假装现在是圣诞节，我是圣诞老人。圣诞老人想给你买些内裤”的话。
Yes. And I started laughing so hard. Oh, that was very hard for me to get through. And I feel like Steve just started making up things. He's like, want a T-back? And I was like, I don't even know what that is. Well, Pam has a talking head where she explains that she's between boyfriends right now. She doesn't need anything sexy.
是的。我笑得太厉害了。哦，那段我真的很难演下去。我觉得史蒂夫开始胡编乱造了。他说：“想要丁字裤吗？”我当时心想，我甚至不知道那是什么。嗯，帕姆有一个采访镜头，她解释说她现在处于空窗期。她不需要任何性感的东西。
So she's going to buy a robe and just turn it into some hand towels. I thought that was really industrious of her. I thought it was ridiculous. I'm like, Pam, just get a pair of comfy sweatpants. Right. That's true. Right. And, you know, just go buy some wash rags. Wow. We have very different responses to this talking head.
所以她打算买一件长袍，把它改成几条擦手巾。我觉得她真的很勤俭持家。我觉得这太荒谬了。我心想，帕姆，买条舒服的运动裤就行了。没错。确实。而且，你知道，去买几块洗碗布吧。哇。我们对这个采访镜头的反应截然不同。
I was offended. I love a good bathrobe. Come on, Pam. Don't cut it up. All right. Well, now Meredith is driving everyone home from the mall and her tire blows out. Probably because she was going too fast. I mean, how many times is my character like, slower? Slower, slower, Meredith. Yeah, Meredith doesn't take care of her car. That tire blows out. Michael has no idea what to do.
我被冒犯了。我喜欢一件好的浴袍。拜托，帕姆。别把它剪了。好吧。现在梅雷迪思正开车送大家从商场回家，她的轮胎爆了。可能是因为她开得太快了。我是说，我的角色说了多少次“慢点？慢点，慢点，梅雷迪思”。是的，梅雷迪思不爱护她的车。轮胎爆了。迈克尔完全不知道该怎么办。
He's like, Pam, maybe we need a crescent, Alan. Yes. That's not a thing. And Pam is like, I'll do it. And she starts to change the tire. We had a fan question from Megan Keel, Ciara Begley, Bethany A, Victoria Nash, and Jamie Hahn. Does Jenna really know how to change a tire?
他说：“帕姆，也许我们需要一个新月扳手。”是的。根本没那东西。帕姆说：“我来吧。”她开始换轮胎。我们收到了梅根·基尔、西亚拉·贝格利、贝瑟尼·A、维多利亚·纳什和杰米·哈恩的粉丝提问。珍娜真的会换轮胎吗？
Yes, I'm. do. So do I. And I've changed one on the side of the road with a friend of mine. Same. Yes. My dad taught me how to change a tire. He would make me practice. And he would not let me get a car until I knew how to change a tire, check the oil, and replace the fluids. I love that our dads taught us how to handle our cars. I just think that's so sweet. Okay. So now we're back at the office. And you guys, Jim goes to grab a yogurt and he sees Pam's sketch of Dwight. And he knows it's Pam. And I just feel like this is just a little moment between the two of them, even though they're not together. Yeah. I just thought it was really sweet. Well, they've purposely not had much Jim Pam interaction
是的，我会。我也会。我曾经和朋友在路边换过一个。我也是。是的。我爸爸教我怎么换轮胎。他会让我练习。在他教我怎么换轮胎、检查机油和更换液体之前，他不会让我买车。我喜欢我们的爸爸教我们如何处理汽车。我觉得这太贴心了。好了。现在我们回到办公室。伙计们，吉姆去拿酸奶，他看到了帕姆画的德怀特。他知道那是帕姆画的。我觉得这只是他们两人之间的一个小瞬间，尽管他们还没在一起。是的。我觉得这真的很甜。嗯，他们特意没有安排太多吉姆和帕姆的互动
for the last three episodes because you know next week is beach games. Oh. And we're going to have a big moment. Oh, are we? They really wanted that to be a surprise. Man, I rewatch Beach Games. I know we'll get there, but I was like, whoa, Pam! Yeah, but even still, they did want some little moment where you were reminded of the affection of these two characters, and this was it, just him seeing the poster. That's all you got in this episode. And it inspired him for the tag, and we'll get to that. I think so, too. Yeah. Well, something we haven't talked much about is the Andy Dwight storyline in this episode where they're going around and they're hanging up these posters. And Dwight is just being so condescending to Andy the whole time. But it's very clear
在过去的三集里，因为你知道下周就是海滩游戏了。哦。我们要有一个大场面。哦，是吗？他们真的想让那成为一个惊喜。天哪，我重看了海滩游戏。我知道我们会讲到那，但我当时心想，哇，帕姆！是的，但即便如此，他们确实想要一些小瞬间，让你想起这两个角色的感情，这就是其中之一，只是他看到了那张海报。这一集里就只有这些了。这启发了他做结尾的彩蛋，我们稍后会讲到。我也这么认为。是的。嗯，我们还没怎么谈过这一集里安迪和德怀特的剧情，他们到处挂这些海报。德怀特一直对安迪表现得非常居高临下。但很明显
to Andy that this is a drawing of Dwight. So he's going along with it. Yeah. And he takes extra flyers, says he's going to put him up all over the town. And there is a great deleted scene, Jenna. It's a quick moment. But as Michael and the ladies are driving back, they come to a red light and Michael looks out the window and sees one of the flyers on a tree, and he looks at it and then looks to camera and goes, idiot. That's brilliant. So Andy's having some fun at Dwight's expense because he's going to just plaster these everywhere. And there is a great scene when at 23 minutes, 40 seconds, Andy shows Dwight three musketeers and goes, have these. And Dwight's like, no, holds these.
对安迪来说，这是一幅德怀特的画。所以他顺着他演。是的。他拿了额外的传单，说要贴满全城。有一个很棒的删减片段，珍娜。是一个快速的瞬间。当迈克尔和女士们开车回来时，他们遇到红灯，迈克尔看向窗外，看到树上贴着一张传单，他看了一眼，然后看向镜头说：“白痴。”这太天才了。所以安迪在德怀特身上找乐子，因为他要把这些贴得到处都是。在23分40秒有一个很棒的场景，安迪给德怀特三剑客巧克力棒，说：“给你。”德怀特说：“不，拿着。”
and he takes the whole thing in true Dwight fashion just starts chomping down on it. Well, in one of the takes, as Rain ate this candy bar this way, he choked and kind of- I remember that. He choked and coughed. And they loved it so much, they were like, will you do it in every take? That's amazing. Well, when Michael and the women get back to the office, Michael asks Phyllis, Karen, and Pam to come into his office while he calls Jan to break up with her. Yeah, he's like, I need my girls. I love you guys. Well, he gets her voicemail and he leaves
他接过整个巧克力棒，以典型的德怀特风格开始大口咀嚼。嗯，在其中一个拍摄镜头里，当雷恩这样吃巧克力棒时，他噎住了，有点——我记得那个。他噎住并咳嗽了。他们太喜欢这个了，以至于他们说：“你能每条都这样演吗？”这太棒了。嗯，当迈克尔和女士们回到办公室时，迈克尔让菲利斯、凯伦和帕姆进他的办公室，他要打电话给简分手。是的，他说：“我需要我的女孩们。我爱你们。”嗯，他转到了语音信箱，他留下了
a breakup message. Oh, and Jenna, your performances, Pam, is so great. You're like, don't leave a message. Oh, God. He's like, you don't want him to leave a message, but he does. And then before he can finish it, Jan walks in. She walks in. Can you imagine? I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, can't imagine. And then he's just like, all right, buddy, talk to you later. Yeah, someone just walked in. And Phyllis and Karen and Pam, they clear the heck out of there. They're like, we're getting out of here. Yes. And Jan then apologizes. She says, I don't like how that phone call went earlier. So I drove all the way here to say, I'm sorry. Can we get some dinner? They awkwardly hold hands. It's such a weird moment. So weird.
一条分手信息。哦，珍娜，你饰演的帕姆太棒了。你说：“别留信息。”哦，天哪。他说，你不想让他留信息，但他还是留了。然后在他还没说完之前，简走了进来。她走了进来。你能想象吗？我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，无法想象。然后他只是说：“好吧，伙计，回头聊。”是的，有人进来了。菲利斯、凯伦和帕姆，她们赶紧溜了。她们心想：“我们快走。”是的。然后简道歉了。她说：“我不喜欢刚才那个电话。所以我开车过来道歉。我们可以一起吃晚饭吗？”他们尴尬地牵着手。这真是个奇怪的时刻。太奇怪了。
Steve's performance in this scene is so brilliant when she starts listening to the message and he's kind of looking off he has this expression on his face it's just brilliant and he's just saying things like maybe we could get Italian
史蒂夫在这一幕中的表演太精彩了，当她开始听信息时，他有点看向别处，他脸上的表情太绝了，他只是在说些诸如“也许我们可以去吃意大利菜”之类的话
Chinese Jan hears the breakup message and she leaves without saying a word but I went to the blogs of Jenny Tan and CAF. What they have?
中国菜。简听到了分手信息，她一言不发地离开了，但我去了珍妮·谭和凯瑟琳的博客。她们有什么？
Well, first of all, Kath said that when they started shooting the scene, Malora had on dark colored nail polish, and Greg stopped the scene because he didn't think that it fit her character, and he had them change it. Oh, wow. And she noted how impressed she was at his attention to detail, that everything mattered.
嗯，首先，凯瑟琳说当他们开始拍摄这一幕时，马洛拉涂了深色的指甲油，格雷格叫停了拍摄，因为他认为这不符合她的角色，他让他们换掉了。哦，哇。她提到她对格雷格对细节的关注印象深刻，一切都很重要。
The smallest details mattered. And I can imagine if that nail polish was distracting to Greg, it might be distracting to an audience member, and it would take you out of this scene. and being in this scene with these two characters was so important. Yeah. That would have been weird to me to see Jan with dark nail polish. I would have been thrown by that.
最小的细节都很重要。我可以想象，如果那个指甲油让格雷格分心，它可能会让观众分心，这会让你脱离这一幕。而与这两个角色一起出现在这一幕中非常重要。是的。如果看到简涂着深色指甲油，我会觉得很奇怪。我会因此感到困惑。
Well, Jenny Tan said that while they were shooting this scene, they gave Malora and Steve the option of doing alternate endings. And that in one, Malora threw something and in another one, she growled at him. She just growled at the end. Grawled. Grawled. And then in another one, she broke down crying. And they were watching the taping with Gene and Lee, the writers, and Gene and Lee asked them their opinion.
嗯，珍妮·谭说当他们拍摄这一幕时，他们给了马洛拉和史蒂夫尝试不同结局的选择。其中一个结局是马洛拉扔了东西，另一个结局是她对他咆哮。她最后只是咆哮。咆哮。咆哮。然后另一个结局是她崩溃大哭。他们和编剧吉恩与李一起看录像，吉恩和李问他们的意见。
And that she and Kath said that they both felt that Jan would be more mad than sad. And they were so excited when they saw the final cut because they felt like they had a little part in picking the ending of the scene. Well, I thought it was the perfect ending. I also think that Jan is not going to spiral out in an office where she is everyone's superior. Yeah. And in front of the cameras. Oh, yeah. I feel like the part, like once she got in her car, maybe it was a different story. But she wasn't going to let them see too much. So the episode is wrapping up. We have Michael's talking head. And Gene and Lee said this was actually a series of three talking heads that they mesh together. And then they had all this B-roll when he's like, he wished for Jan to get over him and Phyllis to get a plasma TV for Pam to. get courage and Angela to get a heart and Kelly to get a brain. Yeah. All of these moments. I just loved it. I thought it was like such a great way to wrap up the episode. And now Jenna, let's discuss the tag. This is amazing. Lee Eisenberg told me that it was actually Randall Einhorn
她说她和凯瑟琳都觉得简会更生气而不是更难过。当她们看到最终剪辑时，她们非常兴奋，因为她们觉得自己在选择这一幕的结局中出了一份力。嗯，我觉得这是完美的结局。我也认为简不会在她是所有人上司的办公室里崩溃。是的。而且是在摄像机面前。哦，是的。我觉得一旦她上了车，可能就是另一回事了。但她不会让别人看到太多。所以这一集快结束了。我们有迈克尔的采访镜头。吉恩和李说这实际上是一系列三个采访镜头，他们把它们拼在一起。然后他们有所有这些花絮镜头，他说他希望简能忘掉他，希望菲利斯能得到一台等离子电视，希望帕姆能得到勇气，希望安吉拉能得到一颗心，希望凯莉能得到一个大脑。是的。所有这些瞬间。我太喜欢了。我觉得这是结束这一集的好方法。现在珍娜，让我们讨论一下彩蛋。这太棒了。李·艾森伯格告诉我，实际上是兰德尔·艾因霍恩
who pitched this tag. Yes, who who pitched the idea of the Sharpie on the mirror, right? Yes. So in this tag, Jim calls the sex predator hotline. He has information. Dwight answers the phone. And Kath noted in her blog that it took Rain six takes to get out the line, Dunder Mifflin slash sex predator hotline. This is Dwight. He had a really hard time saying it, like, because it was making them laugh. And Jim tells Dwight that he saw the perp in the woman's bathroom above the sink. And this is Jim. This is Jim and Pam having a prank with each other without even knowing it. They're just missing each other. Because Dwight runs in the bathroom. He looks in the mirror. And this was Randall's pitch that there
提出了这个彩蛋。是的，是谁提出了在镜子上用记号笔的想法，对吧？是的。所以在这个彩蛋里，吉姆拨打了性骚扰热线。他有信息。德怀特接了电话。凯瑟琳在她的博客中提到，雷恩拍了六次才说出那句台词：“邓德·米夫林性骚扰热线，我是德怀特。”他很难说出口，因为这让他们笑场。吉姆告诉德怀特，他在女厕所洗手池上方看到了那个变态。这就是吉姆。这是吉姆和帕姆在不知情的情况下互相恶作剧。他们只是错过了对方。因为德怀特跑进洗手间。他看向镜子。这是兰德尔的提议，就是
would be a little Sharpie mustache and Dwight would take off his glasses and realize that he is the person on the flyer. It's so great. It's so great. You know, I think it would have been funny without the Sharpie, but the Sharpie nails it. The Sharpie makes it. So that was a phenomenal idea by Randall Einhorn. Well, that was women's appreciation. Do you guys feel like you appreciate women more? I hope so. I had two things I was tracking, Jenna, and I feel like I should share them with you now. Please. First of all, Pam's plant at reception. There's not.
会有一个记号笔画的小胡子，德怀特会摘下眼镜，意识到他就是传单上那个人。太棒了。太棒了。你知道，我觉得没有记号笔也会很有趣，但记号笔是点睛之笔。记号笔让它变得完美。所以这是兰德尔·艾因霍恩的一个天才想法。好了，这就是“女性欣赏日”。你们觉得你们更欣赏女性了吗？希望如此。我有两件事在追踪，珍娜，我觉得我现在应该和你们分享。请讲。首先，帕姆在前台的植物。没有。
It's not a new container. I'm sure the plant is new, but we have recycled a container. Which one is it this week? It is the indigo purple one with polka dots. Callback plant container. I know, riveting. you guys, but I'm obsessed. The other thing I tracked, sorry to parents with children listening, maybe earmuffs. Here is our penis count. Oh, great. So this is the actual times we say the word penis. Not all of the other ways we talk about it, because we talk about it in a lot of different ways in this episode. Okay. Michael says penis twice, and Dwight says penis four times. We actually
这不是一个新的容器。我相信植物是新的，但我们回收了一个容器。这周是哪一个？是那个带波点图案的靛紫色容器。植物容器的回顾。我知道，很吸引人，伙计们，但我着迷了。我追踪的另一件事，抱歉让有孩子的家长们听到了，也许捂住耳朵。这是我们的“阴茎”计数。哦，太棒了。所以这是我们说“阴茎”这个词的实际次数。不是我们谈论它的所有其他方式，因为我们在这一集中以很多不同的方式谈论它。好的。迈克尔说了两次阴茎，德怀特说了四次阴茎。我们实际上
only say the word penis six times in the whole episode. See, so if your grandma hadn't turned this off, she would have only had to hear it five more times. Didn't matter. Didn't want to hear it one time. Click off. Finished. Well, and now we're finished.
在整集中只说了六次“阴茎”这个词。看，所以如果你的奶奶没有关掉它，她也只需要多听五次而已。没关系。一次都不想听。关掉。结束了。好了，现在我们结束了。
But we'll be back next week with Beach Games. Beach Games is so great. And Jen Salata is going to send in some audio clips. She has some phenomenal stories. I can't wait. Can't wait. We'll see you then. See you guys. Have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
但我们下周会带着“海滩游戏”回来。海滩游戏太棒了。詹·萨拉塔会发来一些音频片段。她有一些精彩的故事。我等不及了。等不及了。到时候见。再见，伙计们。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins. And our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯。我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。